[Applause]
[Music]
you
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect hey what's up guys do as
Yol here I hope you're having a dope ass
day I here with my co-host Marty O'Neal
what's up folks what's up this is the
dope as usual podcast we're here to talk
about life a lot of problems and
accomplishments everything in between
sorry we hit we we're taking rips uh
guys today you guys asked every 8
seconds last time during the premiere
people are like you got to have him back
bro here he's here right now so here we
go guys we're back fan favorite this is
a goblin episode thank you for having me
back I'm very excited to be here again
it's my pleasure we were mident sorry
guys we were mid-sentence I went no we
got to come back we just started talking
again boom have I ever ever followed and
did the cop missions in Grand Theft Auto
you said mhm
no you're you're tweaking you have GTA
right now right like you like got it at
the crib you just pretend to be the cop
just get in a cop car and there's an
option to press a button oh yes yes I
pressed it but I've never really vigant
you never did yeah the Vigilante
Missions bro and there as you like get
further into them you start having to
like chase mother and like they're
shooting out the car at you and he
started having to do like crazier then
just like pull up on one guy you know it
gets more lit
I haven't done that but like I said I
like to when you spawn and you see
someone running the cop's chasing him I
will chase him and do the The Weave run
and knock into them see what happens I
think it's like human nature to to it up
in GTA I think if you like follow the
law in GTA you're terrifying as a person
like you scar [__] or a child or my
cousin honestly child my kid I'm like
this could go either way this like we
got on this topic cuz Mar's like got a
child
so innocent like so innocent that's it I
think that's what it is they're like
holy yeah since a little kid following
all the street signs not going on red
not hitting anybody not causing like and
then we show up the opposite which is us
when we like no C4 the whole line of
traffic yep blow them all watch them all
blow up cam did like a like you'd see a
board slide a skateboard like I think
that's what it's called like a grind he
did that with a plane on the mountain
though I
possible he came and slid on the edge of
the mountain with the plane like a going
yeah damn that's fire didn't mean to do
it he didn't mean to do it we like to go
up and then jump out and slam into the
side of buildings is fun as hell all
right I like that one I us us the older
one but the new one my favorite thing is
to go on top of the mountain the
mountain that has the gondola lift the
lift you know what I'm talking about M
and you know the be people with the
binoculars they're always at the edge y
I just go suck them
and sometimes they get knocked out and
fall you see him roll down yes but most
the time if you hit and you just he does
that weird hard kick M you can watch
somebody fall hundreds of yards then
go damn I love it so much it's so fun
cuz you I do the things that you would
never do in life MH but like at the end
yes at the end I a dirt bike there's
always a dirt bike I hit that little
jump right by the right by the uh thing
oh it's so fun it gets kind of it's kind
of scary I know you're not real but when
you're in a car and you're like you're
like oh my God I'm about to die oh my
God I still get like that with GTA dude
I don't know why I still do especially
in shootouts I don't know if I've ever
felt nervous in GTA like I do oh my God
or you know what I get ner I'm still I'm
afraid of the water like in real life so
going in the water in GTA when it's so
you would never go on like a like a boat
in GTA I do I'm saying it just makes me
feel creepy when I jump in and it's just
black a bit
and I'm and I'm swimming
like it just makes me feel like I'm So
Into the damn game so I'm like oh God
I'm in it's that immersive on the GTA
Clips uh that you use like on the
gameplay footage how do you pick that
footage is it just random or is it like
damn this is like my best work right
here sometimes I have moments and I'm
like I'll just edit that I don't really
post that many GTA Clips anymore because
I haven't playing that much um but when
I did it would just be like I I would
kind of know when there a moment that
would be a good clip and then I'd just
hit up my editor and be like yo cook you
[Laughter]
know so um yeah but I I haven't really
been playing that much lately cuz uh the
mode I was playing was U GTA RP and that
is so timec consuming bro takes like you
got to play so many hours every day to
like keep up you know otherwise other
people will like do other stuff and like
you won't be able to do it you know it's
very competitive yeah ever doing it like
playing the game and telling the story
at the same time um not I mean sometimes
on streams I like tell a story while I'm
streaming you know um but no I get the
gameplay and the story separately I sit
down and I like for at least pretty much
all my videos I sit down I like record
the story and then I go play the game
mhm or like vice versa is there any
really new like cracking games right now
we should know about bro oh baby oh
every time I see my PlayStation I go
Nick I need to start playing game you
had so much fun dude MH video games are
the and you said I don't know what I do
with them my life if I didn't have video
games on them I think about them that
sounds fun it's fun you just got to find
games you like you got to figure out
like what kind of game you like you know
I like Grand Theft Auto Everyone likes
Grand Theft Auto though that's like I
just want to do whatever I want try cars
I like realistic like I don't like giant
swords and monsters and Blades yeah but
you people people do whatever the you
want red Dead's fun red Dead's L yeah
Red Dead is sick that's am game but it's
a rockstar game every rockar game is
Bomb I think it's just I want to do
things I can't do in real life but also
like things that could do consequences
weren't there so I think like flying is
just not like a cool thing unless it's
like flying to GTA dude you could fly in
real life you could take flight classes
I'm talking about flying as like as your
body oh yeah okay well strap of
parachute on and you could I guess kind
of do that to sky or uh Doom the new
Doom is wild Doom crazy my cousin played
it like I don't want to play but I'll
watch it play cuz that's it's hard wild
it's like a movie these games have
cinematic pieces I've never seen yeah a
lot of the games have like it's
literally half cinematics and like half
gameplay now like you're just watching
this almost movie as you play the game
it it's crazy as I don't know how I like
it you sit there and watch the whole you
just n bro unless I'm like really really
interested hell no [__] watch yeah I but
not at Time Crisis at the arcade I'll
click shoot to skip oh
yeah what was the uh I found a sick one
what was it like zombie like the Haunted
Mansion one
with House of the Dead yes
yes that's exactly what I was thinking
of bro that game was a banger dude it's
I've never be pass the second level
still I get in that hallway with the
like doctor looking things I think they
were I'm done I die she get a house of
the dead machine and like put it in here
I a Time Crisis that has 4 3 2 and one
how much or no it's it's four to four
and three or four and five and then two
and one I can't remember it was
8K for the whole time crisis machine
whole thing dude dude honestly that's
worth it that's like a lifelong
investment like you could play that
forever you can get maintenance on that
like dude that's actually worth Time
Crisis player I'm I finally beat it I
think I posted it like last year I
finally beat the game
but like my back will hurt about level
two cuz I'm like this like cop always
like this but bro you should see it I am
murking fools head shots head shot I
love Time Crisis I'll do this
one that's how I shoot fire you tap your
trigger
finger I hit him like this bro it's fun
time oh we got to get it [__] yeah split
it and we'll just keep it in
my like I'm down bro honestly I'll throw
too and I'll just come through and play
it how fun I'll throw on it we should
get a Time Crisis sponsor and be like yo
we'll get a clip every single are the
devs of that even around anymore like is
that what does that mean are are the
people who made that even around like is
that even still alive yeah Time Crisis 5
is new oh I saw dve bu there's a new
Time Crisis it has like a machine gun it
has a handle wait that's fire though
yeah that's sick
it is it not as good different I don't
know it's a little it's like it sounds
cool when I was shoot I was a little
different I don't know we're into see
look what happens to video games get
lost we'll talk about for maybe five
hours bro there's a million video games
that you got to play there's just so
many you ever played zup what the zup
it's on Sega it's just shapes that and
they move around it's a kid game I used
to play with screen it is kind of like
it's like the things in the water with
the shapes you shake them try to get on
on the the the loop it's kind of like
that but a game except it's like nothing
it does
what about games on the iPhone is there
anything that's like for a long time in
ter like mobile stuff there's some fun
stuff to like with Call of Duty made a
mobile version that's good really yeah
bro you can actually play mobile Call of
Duty and it's decent like a lot of
people play it I couldn't imagine
playing on my phone I could I I never
play it I would just it would die so
fast it's uh it's popular a lot of
people do play it but um on your phone
playing game don't you see yourself
going moving t Tex well I just missing
60 text yeah I agree I never play games
no no I'm playing a game the only thing
that you could really play on mobile
decently bro RuneScape app is good we've
talked about RuneScape before haven't
weape app is good I still don't know
what we it's a game I haven't played
still it's game yeah Roblox we talked
we've talked about Roblox yes Roblox is
crazy have you seen like some of the
things that they've been able to make
Roblox is almost like a platform more
than like a game in itself like people
make games within Roblox out of like
Roblox assets and like they mod the game
right like Sims not really no never
played Sims I just a world you build
that's all I have I mean you could could
make a version of The Sims in Roblox
honestly roller coaster extreme so what
people do is they make versions of other
games in Roblox so there's like a Call
of Duty in Roblox that looks like Call
of Duty like the graphics I swear to God
they're good it looks like cod like it's
insane a world within a world yeah it's
like a like a game within a game and PE
like Roblox is just
like no one's playing Just Roblox
they're always playing like some sort of
game mode on there and there's just a
million different game modes that people
have made some of them are like very
questionable and
horrible played a valve index that my
brother has the things that come from
the ceiling the the valve index is sick
I get I'm sad cuz I get sick I get most
sickness oh I feel that I I uh I used to
index but um you create worlds you ever
do the game where you my brother can do
the coding [__] no I never did that bro
he created a world it's like it's just a
big Warehouse you he he was Spider-Man
he was a bunch of different people he
was swinging web what the hell but he
has like eight buttons this guy pops up
a warrior this guy's a this this guy's a
civilian this guy's a Call of Duty guy
one guy has a gun and you press it and
he'll just them there's three tables of
any type of knife you can think of any
gun you can think of any explosive and
it's sad we talked about it before but
like the guys talk to what's up man and
like you know you can grab him by the
head and just shove a knife right in
their neck and you can see them and you
hear and like their mouth's open with a
knife going and you can see the knife
it's disgusting I like I did a lot of
these in the
ear oh but I was Spider-Man swinging web
too Spider-Man is fine it was and you
just do this and it makes you go higher
you're going to have to Jake Johnson
about this I was merking have you seen
the Apple Vision Pro I no I've been seen
the commercials for it I have a Mis
understanding Apple Vision like
classes not really dude the Apple Vision
Pro is probably the craziest thing
they've ever released what is it it's um
an augmented reality
headset um it comes out in like two days
what pre-orders happened like a week and
a half ago it's
$3,500 what does it do what does it do
no no no honestly you should look up
like a video at some point while we're
like whatever at some point today just
look up a video it's augmented reality
so if I had this headset on right it's
like a VR headset um it has a battery
life of about 2 hours not plugged into
anything uh it has scanners that scan
where your eyes are and projects them so
the like you would see where my ey like
you would see my eyes yeah right um it
tracks my eyes so I'm looking around and
I have like a Mac OS interface in my
vision at any time I need and I control
it with my eyes and my fingers so I can
look around right and if I let's say
want to open an app I just look at the
app icon it just knows where my eyes are
looking I just pinch and it'll open the
icon right I can scroll like this I can
put Windows anywhere I can attach things
over people like I can put a timer up
and just put it anywhere I want within
my field of vision within the whole room
it's crazy as you have a whole computer
at your disposal you have a whole
computer at your disposal but like this
Tony Stark style yeah Tony Stark style
you're and no one else can see it porn
like that bro no one else can see that
going to be teaching class while
watching porn y y but hey what's up it's
over with dude the horny perv teachers
it's over timer skin mode where you
can't tell that it's on pretty soon this
just just cam in your face so it's a
future we're here it is we're here give
it 10 years and it'll be crazier weird
like it's already here though all right
I'm kind of here for it a little are you
I'm here not for that I'm not put [__]
on I'm here for this ding I press a
button go oh wait that's Alexa but not a
[__] it it's Alexa never mind open my
blinds turn the music on if it just
projected a hologram I could kind of do
that with I'd be okay with that too yeah
bro so you can that's so sick you can
FaceTime people in it right you can
FaceTime people and video call people
and it scans your face right and creates
like an AI like Recreation of your face
Power Rangers they're going to put us in
a it's Black Mirror Time yep it's here
it's Black Mirror time they're going to
do a facial scan and everything you
think and talk look it's over mhm over
it it has all your memories goes through
none of that goes through your Instagram
scans every single thing you like to
wear and just makes it an image of you
and that image of you is FaceTiming
people going hey racist stuff racist
stuff and and then you're is that how AI
revolts it just starts calling all my
homies and dropping like
hards 100 no no no
steel Titan like hardest RS you've ever
heard oh no steel titanium like the hard
like the [__] like the with the
anvils
and and wildy
coyote just going to get us all
cancelled I'm here for it you're here
for it I don't know kidding man I'm
kidding if I can go hey Alexa turn on
the actually it does do that in Vegas
Alexa open the blinds open the it's
already here it was sick as hell but
where did you stay at the wi yeah I
stayed there before too and I was amazed
bro I could be like and I unpluged her
I'm
like no I left it in I was like that's
sick I left it in I could talk to it I
don't like it knowing and I uh I will
not understand I don't understand what
you're saying I just started cussing at
her she does not appreciate it neither
does Siri Siri will shut off have you
ever talk sir enough she'll shut down
I've given L like you you you should do
it you should do it until she shuts down
she shitty stuff to me when I wasn't
even like saying anything to her she'll
give me you got a little attitude out of
siries I like it really a little sweetie
pie to me I don't know because I know
you love technology world you're like I
got the MacBook I got the iPad bro oh
you're connected I have a smart bed
they're going to just fold my ass down I
got the airpod Max pissed at me start
folding I'm connected I saw I forget
what show it was but it was like
technology took over and it took control
of all the Teslas and then it would like
like it took a couple Teslas down the
freeway stopped them took a couple more
slammed them into the back slammed them
into the back slammed them into the back
until it just clogged up all the
freeways of
Teslas you mean something that could
happen tonight this is why I bought a
gas car gas car yeah no no that's scary
man you seen War of the Worlds or World
War Z where all the people start
climbing Teslas could do that go 85 com
miles away until trans Beast bro one day
they get a software update and all
Tesla's just morph together into a giant
Beast it's start smashing buildings in
LA and [__] and then it's going to start
smashing gets to LA and goes yeah oh
[__] we got a
charge yeah they go down to Super
TR oh [__] then that's that's all that
happens it takes 12 hours like and then
we find out like oh you were a villain
this whole time
huh oh dude let's talk about real things
speaking of carus oh last time you came
right we had the olive green BS correct
yeah not
anymore who's at fault uh not me good
it's all matters yeah yeah
uh so uh that car got total some dude
speeding and his dad's
gt63 o ripped the front end of my off um
were you in love with it I love I like
the car a lot yeah but um you know I the
thing is like I didn't really drive that
much and like I had a nice car but the
thing is like I don't I don't drift it I
don't like race I don't really like even
drive fast bro I'm like I'm a commuter
you know I get in yeah I go like 85 in
the fast lane like just just go you know
like it's fast I'm from Illinois bro
California fast bro Illinois that's like
if you're going slower than that you're
getting cut off what bro speed limits
there I mean usually they're like 70 75
but um oh so just smash it oh I'm going
like 90 everywhere oh yeah like 9095 but
I'm saying that's pretty that's pretty
fast for the average person I I go fast
I'm going dog I'm not get out of my way
you know so um I mean I I like the car
but the payment in the insurance was and
uh getting it registered and then
insured out here was just going to be so
ass my quotes for insurance were so nuts
cuz I was already paying almost 600
bucks a month before like I even got
California insurance right so like what
was that do you have any points on your
driving record no I just well actually
uh I I think they're expired by now so I
don't have any points currently but it's
my DUI oh bro yeah but that's not like
like points anymore it matters much very
much but yeah I have I have stuff that
impacts it for sure I have um that's why
though and then my even though I wasn't
at fault still um you know the uh the
accent was probably going to make my
next like if I wanted to replace that
car chance be even worse um and I just I
was like man and I went to uh so I went
to two BMW dealerships because I was
going to look at an
m550 and I was like this is pretty good
it's like a it's like an M5 but it's
like comfier it's like a little detuned
um but it was still like 550 horsepower
or something I was like that sounds cool
you know I'll check it out got in there
had no apple carplay you had to you had
to do a
subscription I was like bro I'm not
doing this like this is crazy I'm not
paying a subscription you didn't get the
car because of that I didn't get the car
because of that bro a subscription for
Apple carplay I'm not doing that are you
kidding me on a car that's already going
to depreciate hel I got to pay a
subscription to use Apple car play in
that hoe do you use apple cardplay yeah
every day oh I don't use it at all I use
it every day how much does the payment
it was like I think it's they charge
like what 20 bucks a month it on
principal it's on principal that's right
I'm a man of principles right I'm a man
of principles of over there so [__]
expensive the weed is a different story
the weed is a totally different story I
agree with
that don't try to up saw me on this
goddamn and that was the second
dealership I went to because the first
one I went in right and uh I had an
appointment at 3:30 okay with a dude
named Bob [__] you Bob if you're out
there um and Bob was like oh yeah uh
I'll be right back right you know I'm
just helping a customer real quick so I
wait for 30 minutes right past the
appointment the car was like it was an
amazing deal that they had listed right
and it was it was nice I was like okay
I'll go check it out um I waited for
like 30 minutes he comes back car sold
he sold to that person I don't know who
he sold to but he was like oh yeah that
car sold earlier like but I can show you
this I like all right bro like so I left
there I went to the next BMW dealership
then they showed me a bucket that I had
to pay a subscription destion for Apple
carplay I'm I'm not doing that so I left
the dealership and I was like you know
what no it's a bucket I'll I'll figure
I'll figure something out and we were
about to drive past a Toyota dealership
and I was saying in the car I was like
What if I just bought like a like a
chill car and just got it over with what
if I just bought a commuter car and we
were driving past Toyota and I was like
pulling that and um I went in there I
was like I want a brand new car I want
whatever the like most chill option you
I don't want an SUV I just want you know
what's the
cheapest right so they showed me a
Corolla I love it they're just like yo
this guy's ready to
buy got him um so they showed me a
Corolla and they showed me like the the
Le I got the top trim level cuz it had
like the safety features like the extra
[__] so my car it has like the lane
assist and the automatic cruise control
so on the highway I just put my hand on
the wheel and drives like I don't really
even even turn the
wheel it it does all that for me I
turned that off of my car cuz I like I
don't want my car moving by itself it's
really good though it's what it does
it's really good yeah how long did it
take till you trusted it and we like
couple hundred miles and I was in there
you know not that long oh also these are
the the gold papers these are theal or
whatever yes I haven't tried them I
haven't tried these either I'm very
intrigued now
yeah um so hold on real quick mhm
speaking of things mhm you text me let
me set this story up then you take it
away you text me the other day a certain
company I won't say a certain company
I've been doing a campaign for we're
about to finish a company's campaign for
this promo Nick was doing and he goes
these mother just PayPal reversed the
payment on Char charge back after he's
already doing the videos charge back on
him after he's done on the deposit or
the whole crazy yeah so so what you do
Nick listen what' you do you text me
first let me explain the story a little
bit why would you like let me give a
little backstory bro because it makes it
sound it makes it even crazier when you
learn the details right so um they had
emailed me two days prior to the charge
back and it went to my spam because they
didn't reply to the original thread they
started a new one right it went to my
spam I didn't see their email the next
email I got after that was in the
original thread and it was them them
telling me about the charge pack so I
was like what the I didn't like I went
and I looked CU they were like oh like
you haven't responded so I went and I
looked at my spam that's when I saw the
email normally I just get hoopla on my
spam I check that once a week I just go
in there type in Goblin if there's
nothing I'm out you know i't heard that
mother I'm not scrolling that [__] um
but uh it's a good ide so they emailed
me they charged back me but they said
they still wanted to book a video for
the next month can we pay you with the
Buddy D we pay that's what I'm saying so
I'm like I said to them I was like why
would you not just like ask like if it's
really really like if you have a problem
with like whatever happened this month
like why would you not just book next
month like you why would you not just
use that money for next month like or
just email me and ask for a refund they
never ask for a refund either they just
charge back me um which as you know you
know your PayPal that's a lot worse than
just like that's a lot more than just
the money right that can get you limited
that can get your like I don't use
PayPal they're just dicks use Z I mean I
try to but they insisted on PayPal and I
was like got you that's so they could do
that and don't you zel with
you I've never been paid by that company
oh I did a video with him like five
years ago just because like I'll do a
video I'm going start doing YouTube and
that's why I just made a video just to
just to make it yeah I don't know so
they um I was pissed bro I was so heated
I like couldn't believe it um so I was
like dude why would you not like try to
work someone out with me you know like
you could if you if you're telling me
like oh we want to book a video next
month you're just gonna PayPal me again
and like pay fees and like do all that
[__] again so annoy seriously you know
yeah what are you talking about um so I
was like [__] this [__] bro uh and they
said some snarky they said some like
really snarky they were like it's
nothing personal just business and I'm
like they said that in the email and I'm
like what the [__] like what are these
guys on dude um so I was like [__] it
bro and I I went to their like website
and I realized it didn't have the do
their brand and I'm not going to say it
but I bought it and I made it redirect
to my
sh and then
um best [__] I was in my dining room and
you text me I went do it yeah that's
funny you know the site have you have
you checked the no your check it out
check it
out no did they respond to that at all
oh yes yes oh yeah wait they talked to
you hold on hold on you haven't told me
anything else let's
see you
bastard I me guess I knew to his
we I love that well played I mean the
[__] was getting like 200 200 hits a day
I was like that's good bro one of those
mother big company um not really but
this URL was really good oh okay like
this URL for some like I feel like I
could this you know you probably saw
that the second I did it it went
straight to it you know how to I'm so
unsavvy you know how to do that redirect
it yeah epic see this is what happens
when you know how to do computer you put
a tracker on so you can see how much is
coming through
that now you're going to try to like
charge bro I got hella [__] uh [__] set
up for the only gas like back in I have
hella [__] set up bro cool
y so hold on I Tred everything what
happened so I got the domain I was like
Hey guys like listen
my first response was just like bro I
[__] bought your.com you
know [__] bought your.com if you want
to buy it back I want the charge back
money plus what I paid for it otherwise
I'm just going to keep it you know and
um they expect that yeah no they didn't
expect that why would they not have
gotten that I was just I don't know bro
I I woke I had just woke up and I was
super mad normally I probably wouldn't
have bought but honestly it was like
really cheap too it wasn't like a ton of
money uh I I leas that [__] Bro fin you
can Finance it bro it's like $100 a
month 0% interest [__] yeah I finance
that [__] hell yeah I didn't pay that
[__] up front I can cancel it whenever I
want more
disrespect I'm so happy what they say um
Well they um they couldn't they were
like we don't have the budget buy back
you know and I it's just like have the
budget you stole my money back where's
that money yeah yeah what they're they
claim that they're doing this out of
like an apartment which I don't believe
they've been around for years who gives
a [__] if they are it doesn't matter
they already paid you got the promo and
then wait I want my money back well it's
it's like how can you ask me to do
something the following month and then
take the money back this month like why
would you not just be like hey let's
just use that next month what like
that's probably not a company the other
thing is too in the email that was sent
to my spam they didn't ask for a refund
or they didn't mention anything about
that either what was the problem why
didn't they feel like they got their end
because I didn't respond to that
original email did you do the promo I
had the video done I hadn't posted it
yet but oh they were waiting on it oh
yes yes they were just running out of
money on bills or some [__] and just
started charging yeah for like a few
days bro but like it's it's not even the
amount of time it's like they never
communicated with me they were never
like like yo like I just think it's
incredible they said like yo we need the
video by this day we're going to charge
back they were just like yeah you know
this is for this month you know like did
you put them on last on Twitter and Sh
no no I didn't say don't say their name
no cuz then this just promo they wanted
in the beginning no I didn't say
anything publicly I'm still not going to
say the name but like but dude I love it
what a damn what a win you put sizy on
blast the one time right hey that work
hey rightfully so yeah don't be
answering back
explain I mean bro I had just I had done
some promo for them and I had done a lot
of free promo for them you know I've
done a lot of stuff with a lot of
different brands I feel like over the
years and like a lot of them are really
cool you know I have a lot of good
relationships with some cool people but
um stzzy I did a lot of free stuff for
them for a long time and for one video I
charged them and they finally like
agreed to actually like give me a budget
um because before like I I had told them
like hey I can't do this for free
anymore and they just kind of like
ghosted me and then they hit me up again
they're like oh okay yeah like we have a
budget whatever um I did the video and
they just didn't like they paid me for
months bro like months and like I was
they kept giving me it was one thing of
like I I can understand a delay if I'm
just told about it you know like I'm
totally cool like delays and [__] just
like if I'm told up front about it but
they kep telling me they kept telling me
like yo this Friday this Friday and they
did this [__] for like four weeks dude
and I was like I was finally like yo I'm
not going to have another Friday like I
don't have another Friday like I'm we
got to get this paint
um it's so annoying like you're going to
turn me into a goddamn Bill CL they just
left me on red at one point like they
just left me on red and all I said was
just like hey could I just get a an
update like an update on the payment
status they just left it on red bro and
I'm like all right like okay dude it's
been months at this point I got left on
red um and I think one of the
frustrating Parts about it is as soon as
I tweeted one thing about it I was paid
20 minutes later it's in 20 [__]
minutes that's that done that for two
you liter text me and went they paid me
it was it was minutes later yeah yeah
yeah you couldn't done that anytime that
that's lame yeah super lame that's lame
not saying the whole company's lame just
whoever accountant is there's cool
people there yeah they're lagging I've
met cool people I've met a lot of cool
people at sizzy yeah they're cool but
that accountant I hope you don't work
there nowhere that's lame
yeah come on Marty goes through this
[__] all the [__] time day it's so
frustrating man it's so frustrating I
really I really dislike it I hate having
to deal with like brand payments and I I
I really try to limit who I work with to
people that I have a relationship with
that I know are good for it you know I
I've kind of stopped like taking a lot
of new people and just got your own
brand now we got permanent marker
cracking right yep permanent markers
cracking we got the jealousy cracking we
dropped some new hash you know we uh we
got the goods we dropped uh a whole lot
of goodies only gas only gas only gas go
to Google go to oh I want say the other
website it's like if you go to this
other Brand's website you can find only
gu the fact that a second I typed it it
just popped up as your site yep I know
you can do that to sites yeah you buy
you can buy whatever URL you want someck
Nike essentially and redirect it to
anything they want bro I mean if you if
you got a hold somehow though if you
could get in there if you somehow got
into Nike's like DNS settings which is
like that's what that is DNS yeah DNS
what do that mean um DNS is like the
settings of the web server gotta so
whenever you buy a website you buy
it.com or whatever you have um you have
to set up the DNS settings in order to
to have like the support emails attached
and have like all the you know all the
stuff set up no thanks so just went it's
really easy bro it's literally like it's
one setting in there to make a redirect
like that really yeah it's one
setting okay so you did that and that
site popped up and that is for o gas hey
what's up guys taking a moment to talk
about one one of our sponsors and this
is raw papers as you can see I have a
ridiculous Contraption on my head but
epic right now on Instagram Go to Raw
life2 247 let them know dope as usual
podcast sent you if you guys already
don't follow Raw on social media they're
constantly doing giveaways constantly
doing give backs fan interaction art
contest so go ahead and make sure you
follow them on Twitter on Instagram and
on YouTube last week we did a $300 raw
box giveaway shout out to for Chuck
Jones shout out to you for winning the
Box all you got to do is follow our
Instagram and follow raw's Instagram we
do collaborative we're just trying to
give back to the fans thank you for
supporting us thank you for smoking the
brand we appreciate it and it's
Christmas time guys wouldn't this make
an amazing gift this is just cool so go
to rawthentic.com to check out all items
they offer this is one of many
ridiculous things there's a frisbe with
a Holiness you can put a joint in there
and throw it to your homie ra thank you
for sponsoring the show thank you for
everything thank you for lacing up all
of our customers all of our friends all
of our fans thank you so much once again
Go to Raw live247 on Instagram let them
know the dope as usual podcast sent you
as always guys thank you so much for
supporting the brands that support us
have a dope ass day what's up guys
taking a moment to talk about one of our
sponsors and this is my bookie Sunday
February 11th is the Chiefs versus Niner
Super Bowl in Las Vegas right now my
bookie we have a whole new deal going on
with the dope as usual podcast let's go
all new customers my bookie right now is
providing 50% match deposit $50 minimum
$1,000 maximum that's means if you put
$50 in they will match you $25 on your
first deposit and remember you're still
betting normally it's just with this
deal this counts says mybookie free play
Say You Win $5,000 extra dollars on the
side it all goes to bet again bet on the
next thing go to the mybookie casino go
play Blackjack do whatever you want if
you want to take advantage of this
remember at checkout on my bookie you
just use dope as usual but if you click
the link in the description of this
video it's already there easily click
the link and it automatically goes to
this landing page also just for signing
up $10 free casino chip go try it out we
hit on our first number remember use our
code do as usual and or go click the
link in the description and it goes
straight straight to it remember guys
take advantage of this if you already
gambling online make sure it's my bookie
and you're supporting your favorite
podcast thank you all so much for
supporting the brands that support us
back to this episode speaking of being
high he hit me up I'm going through my
records you guys paid me to do a video
we we never did that was seven months
ago oh the the dopest video we're
supposed to do I was talking to CLA
about it earli like you guys realize
that Nick is awesome and hit us up to
let us know you know I owe you a video
like
oh yeah I forgot about that [__] because
what happened was we were waiting on
packaging like we'll get back to him
when we get this new packaging and then
we just hit the ground running and
forgot yep so happens well we have a new
video coming out we'll be doing some
more [__] yeah hit me with some of your
new [__] Bro yeah [__] we Uber here like
he's going to Vegas after let's just
wait till gets back y you know what I'm
saying
um okay so Marty can you do me a favor I
have something right up your alley or
the old Nick's
alley that sounded bad for you I mean
wait wait wait how old though like how
old like 2 years old it could still be
there I I could still have a little like
Speck of it left in me I hope not here
we go can you bring up the things I dm'
you oh oh I didn't even see these can
you bring up the things I didn't want
you to see it yet the DM are you Ser are
you kidding me this [__] is insane you
probably already seen it what you'll see
it right the podcast or to myc yours I'm
extremely intrigued bro bro when I saw
this I went nah that's too fun don't be
doing that [__] to people so a couple
years ago when we first got when you
first came on the show you were
shitfaced yeah right you were shitfaced
which is fun but you were also dabbling
in drugs oh Jesus so we'll overlay this
on the screen but I'm going to show you
right now ready mhm look at this [__]
it's snortable caffeine with the vitamin
B12 in it this is not sponsored I bought
this because I thought it was look cool
this Grand think about the price point
on that I understand about cocaine
cocaine is is that a good price for
pretty much just a leaf that they hador
to I don't know why it's so expensive or
why it's so [__] kick ass key bump
he's hitting a key
bump and the whole
J look at that clob he put on his you
can drown Jasmine in the [__] amount
of sand in this go through another
Industrial Revolution if you didn't know
the history of it that's what happened
smuggled coffee beans
from kid bumping caffeine with B12
powder just do blow at this point it's
supposed to be the legal Co it's a
company just do Coke this this is a
company watch look what he's doing bling
up the dollar sticking the entire Dollar
in holding the end of the dollar have
you seen that before he's holding the
end of the dollar to fill up the whole C
I've never I've never seen anyone do
that with Coke me
either he actually a whole dollar full
[Laughter]
bro at that point just do actually do
cocaine like what are you doing the
legal version like if you're an addict
and you have a job you got a test for I
could see people in their in their cars
doing that did you see him snort a whole
[__] jar in 3 seconds how I mean that
was a whole gram yeah yes what the [__]
I mean all right wait how many grams of
caffeine are in like a drink though that
see but that's through the nose though I
think it's just for the fact that you
can like it rails dude have you ever
seen that he got the jar rolled up the
bill put it in there filled up the whole
bill 95 milligrams of caffeine and a cup
of coffee oh my God all right never mind
so how many coffee up the nose oh my god
oh could that not kill you like no
milligrams yeah milligrams so how many
grams that's a 1,000 milligrams is a
gram oh so it's like a tenth of of a cup
of coffee I mean that's 10 cups of
coffee soring sorry like you just said
why did it take so long for me to figure
them out he said it in the beginning and
I went no no I think it's
[Laughter]
opposite I asked him for his advice he
said the answer sorry bro have you seen
that before what that [__] the
no what's the brand called I don't know
I don't want even say it for people to
go go Google yourself if you want to I
don't want to be providing that but he
didn't say that bre he's like this is
not an ad I just want to let you guys
know honest to God I would not I would
not would not do that no you know what's
funny though vitamin B12 and caffeine
were like oh yeah it's the only natural
and they were like cocaine yeah Coke
yep you ever do the cinnamon challenge
do Coke God you know you know some um oh
God some [__] [__] so when I was uh this
was a few years ago go this is like
probably like 3 years ago at this point
um I had some buddies over and we were
like super [__] up and I used to have
uh I think I told you when I used to
have my Rosen press yeah the little uh
nug Smasher yeah um we tried to squish
Coke just to see what would happen we
put like a Little Rock in there just
like try you're like bro like what have
we made Co crin you made crack when it
started smelling it it it just flattened
for real literally just flat it did
nothing it literally didn't no oils no
nothing not really no like did you eat
it
like a little chip I mean we just pulled
it out and like kind of gummed it we
just like scraped like it was now it's
it was like a extremely like thin
chip but we didn't put like a huge Rock
in there or anything so we didn't want
to waste it we were scared of wasting it
we were like remember list strips what
if they had C strips bro I love those
things they little C
ones yo first person in inventos is Rich
dude imag bet off bet you there's some
rich guy there's a rapper that used to
I've heard of this before that you put
like heroin and V and mix it with vising
drops have you ever seen people do
that hero drops they put it in their
eyes would that get you [__] up I've
heard of people putting Asin in their
eyeballs oh well they're talking about
mixing like the heroin what you like
like boil it out heroin and Visine like
what does the Visine add to it though I
think it's so you can so you can drip
you can just Dr maybe it's maybe it's
just herin in a [__] dripper I don't
know that sounds scary so you don't got
to shoot it God probably so you don't
got to shoot would that work through the
I'm not I'm not well ver heroin yeah I
don't know how heroin really works I've
never tried that [__] that Heron my hair
on yeah so um I don't know did you watch
Griselda no I haven't watched it you
watched it ready I've watched this only
a couple episodes AER yeah it's yo we
got to get her son on here man I reached
out I don't know if like I didn't want
to like you know what I mean I just
reached out if you wanted to come on we
reached out you got to be ballsy you got
to just hit him up be straight up listen
like yo so we got this this snortable
caffeine we got [__] snortable
caffeine we're smoking dope smoking dope
snorting caffeine taking B we got pounds
of gas can we please can we rip the ball
yes please you're gonna you're gonna
love this damn this damn
series what I don't want to give it away
there was no moment of that though I was
waiting should have been right at the
end they should have ended it should I
retrieve the
ball yeah so we're we're putting water
in one of our bongs and Nick's like I'm
going to Vegas to Glass Vegas I brought
my sa so the rare the rare bong rip
moments coming up on the show all right
um and also we have weed but Nick also
brought better weed than everybody has
so yeah this is what happened the guest
and then bought expensive ass aroan
pineapple for no reason we're just what
a what a morning what a morning
right 11 in the morning this is our
earliest episode ever I think it is is
it really I like it wow I like doing
this yeah this is I be up earlier too I
been waking up I have the Sleep Number
MH so I found out I have to sleep
slightly tilted up and when I'm like
this it's been a life changer I wake up
and says 86% out of 100 rest I'm like
oh so my sh sleep score when I started
was 3 four and now it's at 86 34 is
trash yeah yeah Dam what does that mean
it's just your sleep number and your and
your Rhythm and how long you slept and
how your heart where you getting this
number the Sleep Number bed it it it
calculates everything for you it's
pulling that info just off your body
while you're sleeping what because it
has it calculate your heartbe heart rate
it's as comfortable as you want it to be
it gets harder or softer do whatever you
want forms to your body you can put a
mode on that if you move it'll fill in
where's the it'll fill in the gaps I'm
looking it up how much sleep number oh
that's where that's where it goes off
the rails you should do it though
because and just do payments like I am
okay okay hell yeah I'm doing payments
that sh too
expensive got mattress and the frame and
the frame is the one that moves so you
have to buy the frame also if you took
payments on that [__] I'm pretty
terrified I take payments on
what no I'm not buying a bed like
that how crazy is this like I I've never
looked at these the mattress and the
frame together was like almost like it
was like 11
something
11,000 if you got I have horrible back
problem remember I have a [__] up
spine so I was like dude I got it I got
to try I got to try I was like I got to
try and night one I woke up remember I
called you like I woke up with no back
pain this morning cuz I usually wake up
like ah and I had to like 10 15 minutes
of me like try to like get my hips out
of like oh I hate it it's like my hips
are okay so all the muscles around are
doing this and they wake up like like
when you start twisting your shirt and
then when you let go just a big wrinkle
that's how my back feels when I wake up
like but not today M I woke up fly
today all right let's do the bongs all
right [__] get it the bed was per
it's it's incredible bro um it's just
too expensive is there a grinder around
here
yeah it's just way too expensive man
thank you no problem okay let's get on
to oh something else already had some
really good notes Here mhm and something
I saw you post y you for the goblin
Channel got your plaque so it was
actually for my second channel oh and I
just changed the name on it to Goblin
instead of goblin 420 change it yeah you
can change the name on
it bro you get the plaque on the second
Channel and you change to topola and you
have a plaque oh oo that's genius
actually can we order another one for
the you get multiple yeah you can get
multiple say the name well I don't know
if you can change it after the initial
order is the thing oh I got my adventur
I think after you lock in the name on it
you you can only reorder copies I think
ah damn it just got hit 100K on a
different Channel we got to get more the
there you [__] go yeah got 80 yeah 20
more in the clip Channel and you've got
a plaque yep love it there you go okay
so you got your clip a damn it I was
like yo the weed plaque for the channel
how okay you're Savvy over here
redirecting websites and changing names
on plaques I got to start thinking dude
like these are little things I got to
start thinking I'm doing what I got to
do man oh my God so you got you got it
uh you got your award and drop of 420
how' they give you an award on 420
Channel I have no idea BR all things
they were like no the for I just kind of
post stream highlights and clips so I
think that's why it's the content yeah
it's just like chill [__] on there none
of it really gets restricted that is it
monetized
yeah I need to post on there more but
okay look it the adventures of Thomas
Channel The V old Channel it got
demonetized I was like oh I don't cuss
or smoke or anything oh [__] so I
changed the name to the adventures of
Thomas just to get it away from doola
and I re I retried for monetization and
they denied me because they said it's
associated with DOA channel oh that's
not good that's not good what the [__]
they demonetized this channel recently
and the clips because they said the
clips was associated with this channel
even though the clips were all cussing
and stuff like that bro we just have to
accept that ad revenue from YouTube is
probably never going to happen for us
yeah it's probably never going to happen
for us it's just I wish they would go no
don't ask again cuz that's that's what
because they always give it back a 3
months later you you can reapply now
like all right did we do something
different that's what my thing I'm like
Oh we must have did something different
you continuously reapply they always
give it back to us changing [__] and try
to like [__] about the bro we completely
stopped the cussing on the clips Channel
they still deny they they took it back
oh I never reapply I just gave I'm
scared that when they go look at my
channel Chan again Smite this [__]
yeah um I have a I tell you I have a
strike from October
2019 that's still like on there it's
still on my channel and I you weren't
able to take the little course I pressed
everything it's up there I don't know
what happened two months ago it popped
up and says I can get rid of it and then
it said it'll get rid of it this month
what it's been on there for four years
why are they on your [__] ass four
and a half years almost why are they on
your [__] ass like that I got mine uh
my warning is
gone my warnings G on with this [__] is
crazy and then I watched a breakdown the
other day uh Steve will do I've seen him
on Instagram I've seen him never really
watches stuff I watched the the story
behind Steve will do you know they
raised his whole Channel yeah they smoke
his [__] yo he's not even allowed back
on mhm at all yeah once you get like
like ban banned you can't come back what
that is insane you're not allowed to
appear on YouTube again like it's kind
of scary isn't it if if like one channel
that someone owns gets banned
dunzo I watched this thing about him and
like he didn't have any strikes just
like I did when I got deleted cuz I got
deleted too but Marty got it back for me
after talking to YouTube but I didn't
have any strikes either they just took
him off and never gave it
back was he what was he wasn't doing
anything insane was he
I'm oh what what what was he doing yeah
he was drinking like I don't know I mean
we smoke well yeah but he would be like
chugging four bottles of vodka and like
eating two large pizzas in like five
minutes or whatever that's a mukbang bro
no but like over mukbang he would get
[__] up he would say questionable
things you know you'd have like half
naked girls in the videos you know oh
okay okay okay
yeah so okay so they didn't mention that
in the video I mean to be fair I don't
think it should have been deleted but
like yeah he he went a little
permanently banned is nuts a person
that's tough yeah that's shitty that's
super shitty mhm you feel like overdoing
it for or was he doing too
much some would say he was doing too
much I think they overdid it I don't I
don't
I think YouTube rules should be far
looser than they are I think if you're
not promoting like you know real like
serious harmful [__] like [__] I
don't know bro
like you know like bad [__] you know
you're not like copyright like [__] like
that you know like just stuff that is
actually
illegal shouldn't be like have you
shouldn't have a problem you should be
allowed to to post freely and age
restriction shouldn't Shadow Man the
video either like the video should still
like still be recommended and like
allowed to perform you know that's the
big one yeah if if they change that
where age restricted videos could be
recommended to adults I'm bro bad still
going fine yeah it just it they just
don't get recommended at all the views
bro yep my last two videos nuked bro
it's so shitty isn't it weird it's so
shitty I hate it bro cuz like my normal
Story videos are fine bro it's like oh
okay you know get like 100 200k views
like it depends if it's a real are like
300K but then like the Ador ones bro I
never like I rarely break 100K on
those oh no it's hard it's get like 70
of the most isn't it weird it sucks bro
I hate it I've been talking to you about
oh my God they just don't recommend the
content at all and you go to the
breakdown in the analytics and you see
that sad as [__] it's just all subs
there's no new viewers there's no dude
but like uh I had one video I posted it
and I like woke up to check it and we
like
I had like 10,000 views in 10 hours I
went what is I want to delete those
videos sometimes what is happening like
that's not real I just let them marinate
but I and I let it sit I go huh they
eventually catch up people find them no
and then it went then it went but I'm
like for a whole day it just didn't
really do anything and then yeah it's
like it's being hidden mhm I know man
yeah some people the com cuz I do a lot
of comments be like 3 days late then I
get the notification a lot of people
like subbed again six time yep all day
but I mean you know you know what I've
noticed bro Twitter there's so many
[__] Bots that I can't hit 100K cuz
my follow count keeps
fluctuating oh I didn't think about that
there's so many [__] Bots I keep
going from 6 to0 4 to6 to.5 to 7 to5 oh
I didn't know about that bro I'm so
tired you're talking about that girl
Jessica Rosie the two white chicks that
spam the two
porn my God want to see more with the
blue want to see with the thing I'm so
[__] tired of that is you press hide
reply and then once it hides reply it
says do want to block you press block
because if you said block first you have
to go all the way back to the comment
then press hide reply I every post I get
the Spam porn girls posted if you hide
it then people more people will see it
you know what because it's in the hidden
replies and everyone checks that [__] it
could be drama replies there's the
hidden replies aren't actually hidden is
public people can see that [__] there's
a little section what tweet did you do
I'll show you right now no no I'm saying
where did you see hidden replies I
didn't know that bottom right of the
tweet I have no idea there's a section
so it's almost like you pin it well you
go to Every post go to a hidden reply on
Rosie in there s y it's the white chick
yeah do you like me
Smash God a different account every day
different account every day same girl
every day every day every day and now
it's a Mexican chick it changed into a
different chick and then it went back
blond one my [__] for a bit I had a
blond like dude I get it you you're a
porn spam bot but every post every POS
it's so annoying like thank oh this is
great this is great would you smash like
a [__] want to un unhide the picture no
block this ho dude if I see her in
person I'm going to oh my God
headbutt you're going to have to take
care of that you're going to have to do
something not for real I'm kidding but
you're going to have to do [__] every
post every post no no fail okay I'm
going to light this up this is the one I
roll for all of us just to pass around a
little bit all right oh boy so go cast
let's go oh hold on before we get into
that last time you were here you were
just about to move here right is hey is
that the what is that Treasure Chest
grandpa's gun
CH yep and you got the toad oh look at
that it's the Skittles and grandpa's gun
chest
crossed that [__] smells fun see you get
it now
G I like it
um last time you were here you were
about to move right you were about to go
get your stuff uhhuh so now you're here
you've been here what 3 four months y so
now that you're here you've started a
Gob cast it's coming episode one you've
done so far we did uh we did like the
pilot episode uh my friend my good
friend Kyle was out here back in
November and he's not really like the
kind of guy who travel a lot or is able
to so um I was just like yo I know the
studio is not like built out yet but we
need to film this like now like this has
to happen um because he is one of the
guys he's the last surviving member of
the crack smoking crew last surv the
other the other homie died the other
homie died oh there's one other I was
like there's one guy there three of us
yeah one other guy died so uh he's the
the last other surviving member crack
smoking crew the crack Smoky crew um so
I I knew I had to have him on it was a
banger it was a great episode um I'm
really excited to get the Gob cast going
it's very close it's very close nice
with with in February it'll be launching
y that's the plan all right hell yeah
good [__] so gobc uh Who besides like
the obvious weed people who are you
trying to who are you thinking of
getting on what are you thinking I know
you thought about a little bit men you
earlier I really want to get Hamilton
Morris on yeah like drug drug yeah yeah
yeah I I I really like myologist maybe
type of yeah yeah like chemists you know
like I I want to get like Trappers and
[__] I want to get you know people who
have been to jail for like various drug
crimes and like you know I want to I
want to find some dude who's on the run
you know like some [__] like that like I
want I want Aiden to B criminal I'm GNA
have I'm gonna he'll have a mask on I'm
going to have some like armed guards in
my [__] bro like I'm not g to [__]
around um what's it called but uh I just
I want to do like I don't know I want it
to really fit my content I want it to be
like some yeah some real [__] like other
people's experiences with drugs I want
it to be like just an evolution of my
main Channel but don't turn into white
soft white underbelly and go your
crackhead Fu [__] that no [__] that
today we got maybe one of them crackhead
Cindy oh God put your pants on like just
oh you have to go on patreon she's bad
though oh
[__] what if she's bad though she's
definitely something's wrong with her
she smoke crack lives outside you know
what she's entrepreneur good for no rent
yeah exactly putting it all into her
clothing business if it all fell apart
would you not go vibe in an RV like
we're going I am I am poor and grew up
in the country and diesels I can live on
the floor oh I do not give a [__] like
we're living on the floor I can I could
sleep sleep without back so our heads
don't sleep in the what was it we sleep
back to back so our heads aren in the
mud that's how I sleep like bubble and
Forest bro did you see uh Ken flores's
RV story on here bro from your local
Hometown Ken Flores I think I did but I
know about Ken Flores he's a yeah he's
from my area yeah he brought he was
bringing me up for the show and we
talked about you on the show but he used
to watch St [__] yeah his I'm like I'm
glad two didn't bump into each other cuz
he's wild what was he saying bro I don't
want to give it all the way okay you
need to just go watch the clip okay
let's just sayth hookers RV oh what you
know those nights when you wake like he
when he described it I was like am i
title of the video's first time trying
meth and
hookers but bro this is the thing is
like you know this feeling like it's 6
in the
morning people are probably passing out
I still feel like the drugs but they
probably weren't clean so I feel like my
Skin's like oily I'm kind of sticky from
sweating and smoking and drinking all
night but now like the sun's coming up
and I can hear birds and I'm like oh got
got of a chill I I'm a I'm a [__]
addict like that feeling of
like it's gross dude it's disgusting I
feel like a feel like it's a slime that
you can go the addict slime oh so when
he was describing I'm like oh
god oh I hate that feeling of like
regret like why am I doing drugs
yes yeah he talked about the Moment of
clarity in the middle of it all why am I
here well I told you right before he
even said and I laid down I went sobered
up cuz I knew like if that was me and I
laid on the bed and went the son what am
I doing I was raised by a [__] parent
what am I doing and you got to watch it
bro it's disgusting you're going to love
it [__] yeah but in the best way
possible so we got to link you guys up
when he goes to the hometown show and if
you're home that would be I went to a
show uh recently his live show M
ridiculous like it is wrong it's great
it's right up your alley you he's a fool
dude think about this what I thought of
this question earlier I watched this new
Swamp stories on Diddy that came out
today he did swamp stories oh oh oh okay
he did a documentary on Diddy M uh and
by the end of this documentary I'm like
damn Diddy's the biggest degenerate of
all time if this is true Diddy's a crazy
[__] I've seen about him if any
of this [__] is true he's he's up there
and he's my first favorite rapper so
this kind of breaks my heart bro what
was the oh my God I saw some crazy [__]
about him recently I feel like I've just
been seeing a bunch of news articles
about him doing crazy [__] like past
like yeah it's all unraveling these
documentary dudes on YouTube are
starting to piece this all together
since the and he started off with Andre
harell from Uptown records I almost
signed a record deal with Andre harell
we used to do Blaze track video messages
back and forth and [__] and he's wrapped
up in this on the
documentary oh Marty Marty Marty huh hey
got du that one Marty yeah you left the
music industry for the podcast Marty's
name on the Diddy list no I think Marty
was like when what he himself out of
that room is what happened I hear I was
trying my damn this to get a record deal
they [__] you can't get on those blue
eyes we're not into the blue eyes Marty
I didn't real I had no idea all this
type of [__] was like existed I was
signed with that man horror movie if you
get into this [__] but my question oh
you would have been a very different man
today uh oh who comes to mind when you
think of the big the greatest or the
biggest degenerate of all time the
biggest degenerate oh wow well that's
very subjective you know
from
wow
okay I
mean my uncle Glenn's pretty up
there un Glen is pretty [__] holy
[__] I did not expect anything to do
with I know this man
personally Glen's up there I was putting
this down I was looking at the screen
like like a little picture like oh
that's nice my uncle Glenn felt it I
knew everything about Glenn when he said
that what type of glasses does he wear
brown ones I don't think he has glasses
damn I was way off he uh usually he
doesn't come to the family gatherings
he's not invited cuz he he like sells
oxies all day for to like pay his [__]
entrepreneur
does he do them all day oh so he's your
tic yeah yeah yeah but he's a
functioning businessman too
no give him a little credit Uncle Glenn
he he's not really doing that anymore
he's like too old now he's like [__]
up but he's still just popping him like
a shitload but he's always just been
like I think he does a lot more than I'm
aware of got you know or a lot more than
close enough with him to really know
like all the [__] he does but like if I
from what I know about him I'm fully
aware and like confident that like yeah
he he's popping hella [__] opiates
you know like let's go damn he's lit
maybe he's siipping lean that'd be crazy
old ass
uncle uncle he listens to Hank Williams
and sips
lean the greenest H to Johnny Cash and
poured uh 2 O in a spray cranberry
Sprite cuz he's
head Elvis in a Double Cup Elvis in My
Double Cup oh I like that damn you
topped this bowl to the max this is what
you would call the little steel we
getting high what we getting high oh
yeah this is packed all right here we
go hold on this is a little trick guys
if you didn't know you can transfer
lighter fluid just by hold I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding
yeah that be so sick I'm going to siphon
it out there you
go now uh who made the top 2023 list uh
the weed list I it yeah bro
so the uh the GMO that I brought right
here actually was up there I really
liked this a lot here we got um that
[__] was smoking uh it's like a little
old now you know it's like a mon old now
but still very F you know it's funky of
course here you go nice followup yeah um
the toad was a good honorable mention
the starburst 36 from 710 Labs was my
favorite flower probably like overall
all year um just cuz that [__] was crazy
as hell at the price point too it was
like 10 bucks a grand it was like 280
for this
zip
um and they deliver it to you and it was
the best batch of Starburst I ever
smoked I never tried a starburst weed
strain
bro you're sleeping so hard Nar narcotic
no so here's the thing you would think
Starburst is like some [__] candy
THS right I'm I'm down to try what the
[__] but you you would probably think
it's just some candy right it's it's not
bro it's gas it's gas yeah it it's very
gas
um the 710 Labs Starburst is what yeah
their new flowers is really good dude I
haven't tried this sh a long time it
[__] uh what was I going to say I
think they got like a new grower or some
[__] so they've been they've been
crushing it but damn it I just had a
question in my head and I got high and I
forgot it it was something I've been
high the whole time and like I feel like
I've had to think so hard to answer the
most simple questions you know was
something my first smoke of the day was
that b rip right before we started the
episode I had smoked anything else all
morning [__] it was something Mar you
want to rip sure damn it guys has how's
things been with your mom since you
moved out here my mom yeah it's been
good um I got to go visit her I didn't
really get a chance to come back for the
holidays cuz we were just doing a lot of
[__] you know just moved trying to get
settled in um last time we talked I
think you guys were not in like a good
place or is that not right no we were
good we've been good for a while I mean
honestly since I moved out me and my mom
have been
you know um it was just before I moved
out me and my mom were not not great but
no um like since I moved out of her
place like years ago we've been
good she's much happier now that I'm
I've gotten the hell out of there good
damn it Marty I can't remember what the
hell I was going to say I had it and I
went oh yeah we'll talk about that I
forgot completely but it's okay um your
dad again he oh I haven't spoken to that
dude in years recently that that was a
yeah that was a couple years ago then
that was the last time you talked to him
right yeah yeah yeah two years ago
oh back for the second hit
disgust all right here we go so it's
clean real quick MH I uh I just became
aware uhhuh there's a company I don't
even know the name of the company I try
to find out but I don't I can't find the
information I found information on a
different company okay so there's a he
went on a
podcast and I heard so much backlash
about it but I didn't know who the
person was so I had to look into it okay
this a while back there's a like an ex
DEA agent that owns a weed company what
yeah he's an xde agent and he is
responsible for like putting a lot of
food obviously in [__] jail for this
[__] and now he
owns a weed company and I posted about
it like yo
I posted about it recently cuz somebody
brought it up and I go oh yeah there's a
[__] oh so what it is is the owner one
of the owners of the woods is like an ex
Sheriff that that smoke lounge and I
went oh
okay
huh I don't know about that I don't like
that if you arresting people for weed
you should not be able to make money off
but hold on is a sheriff out here
arresting people for weed that's what
I'm saying like I don't know about the
woods guy uhhuh but I heard about the
other person the reason why I even
brought it up on Twitter because
somebody brought up the woods guy went
whoa what about that other guy he owned
a company who's who's the other one
that's so I don't know the name of it
but he's an X DEA agent and he went on
first smoke of the day which is a sick
podcast I went on there before and
apparently they got hella of backlash
about it for like bringing on a I mean
obviously he's telling a story they're
podcast that's what they're supposed to
do I get it but this guy's a DEA agent
XDA agent I believe that's now owning a
cannabis company that's in
stores so I'm not like sitting here
trying to get like a this fool to get
mad at me but I think that's lame I
don't think should be able to do that be
a silent partner so no one knows that
it's you because you're not going to be
accepted oh he's like being the face of
it yeah he's like he on the show talked
about his own about his own company and
the story behind him being a DA agent
and I posted on Twitter so I want to get
your opinion I posted on Twitter MH and
I had like people go yeah I I agree
that's not that's not right it's
hypocritical and a lot of people like
what people can't change their ways and
notice that and see that the plant is
like a good thing yes you can but then
you want to go profit off it it's
[__] nuts so how do you feel about
this I feel just my opinion there's no
room for them yeah I think I think it's
not right I think uh I think if you've
profited off putting people doing what
you do now in jail like you can't now
profit off doing the same thing I think
it's lame you can't ruin people's lives
because they sold weed and then sell
weed you can't go like damn this e is
fire there's a guy in prison because of
these people that's still in jail
because of these people now they're like
well we have the
COA yeah [__] him I don't know about you
man right step away fromy okay dude for
real because me as a person I will never
sport anything like that can't just cuz
it's not right f how would you really
know I mean he went on a podcast you
shouldn't have shut up about it he
shouldn't have never told nobody he
should have shut up and just run his
company cuz now people know but then
again I don't know the name of the
company so it's not like it's mess then
again I'm dumb I don't remember anything
about people stuff I don't pay attention
to the weed industry like that I get
first smoke I get a lot of updates from
first smoke of the day actually because
they interview a lot of sick
people um but yeah I just want to get
you guys opin I think that was crazy
yeah that's I I don't think that's right
at all the episode got a lot of backlash
that's all I kept seeing was people
telling like Dam I got a lot of backlash
like look at this [__] pain like they
just like you want me comment that they
should have done it bro they take it
down or did they huh did they take that
episode down or is it still up I don't
know like I probably should ask them
take that down he shouldn't have said
anything yeah he shouldn't have gone on
but he shouldn't have ever gone on that
[__] and then I met a man that really
turned open my eyes to the plant and
then I grew for 20 years and like I
don't give a [__] unless he was like
some Advocate this whole time from
inside who was pulling strings if it was
that whole story also you know what you
should do take 10% of your company and
employ a bunch of people that you put in
prison and let them be owners of the
company if it's really about the
plant if it's not it's about sounds like
a monetary beneficiary personal monetary
gain I trying to use all the biggest
words so these policemen understand but
yeah that shit's crazy to me let's uh
just your hit oh it's yours all right
rip it
have you watched episode of the Jake
Johnson's podcast we're about to go on
yeah what so uh how did they rock it
like I know they have call-ins we're
about to go in a couple days do this
other podcast they do Callin and they
when you call in and they try to give
you advice it's literally it I really
it's great I like it that's the that's
the whole show oh okay yeah it's like 30
minutes it's great I love it it's a cool
formula so your formula you're going to
what you say interview a bunch of
degenerates drug deals and people have
been to jail for drug [__] I know a lot
of them I need to talk to them yes I
know a lot of them but like
agent I'm now
the yo I know a shitload of I need to
just find a few dudes that like still
live in the Hood in a few cities you
know and she be like yo [__] call
your homies you know I need something
right we could get all sorts of
different characters but I think you
know it's mainly going to be about just
getting people's stories about like
their experience with with drugs you
know and people most impacted by that
you know here's a little thing I was
thinking how are you going to do it like
person to person talking I mean probably
yeah so I was just thinking when it
comes to stories and it's going to be
mainly about their hard-hitting insane
stories I really like the way Vlad is
focused on the person I like the way
soft why underbelly is focused on the
person but nobody's done like
a not like a newscast but like I was
thinking uh you ever see Matilda of
course remember when all the kids are
like going through their head oh hurry
up and it's like floating in between you
can see the kids coming in like their
faces coming down what if you were just
like floating in the screen as like a
head picture and picture picture and
picture hey but not a picture and
picture like the back the sides are
always black like soft W underbelly or
something with the deep and then you can
just see that would be sick loading so
tell me about your first time it's
almost like a therapy session with this
dude just here's the square the guy's
Focus looking at you but the camera's on
you and you're you're just kind of like
in it mhm not like a square cuz that
look just a little circle that's like
fading around the edges yeah yeah yeah
than like a therapist yeah I don't know
I always just imagine like and there'll
be like a little twinkle when I come in
yeah you know what I mean like
so tell me about the time you tried
crack so what about the fifth time you
went to prison for crack as you floting
I think you could lead people down a
very unique path stories and oh yeah
just just be like oh this guy did crack
too I'm tell you some stories man I
think you get some good fools yeah I
think I mean there's a lot of people
from like different walks of life that
do drugs there's a lot of people that
are impacted different ways as long as
they got a good story you know they got
some fun [__] I'm game you know I love
it now I saw you had two different of
your vehicles stolen by Tweakers maybe
you could interview what bro that I told
you what happened my old Mercedes right
no in the Volvo tweaker squatted my old
house and [__] stole it they to it
out of my driveway told me none of this
I never told you this wait you moved out
here no no so so all right when I lived
in Illinois still uh back when I still
lived in Springfield what is happening
shitty shitty old like crib right um I
moved back up closer to Chicago and then
I moved to LA right so this was this was
two places right yeah this is two places
before right now right so when I was
living down in uh in Springfield
Illinois um I had two cars that were
like kind of broken down I didn't really
like have the money to fix them that at
that time you know uh and I had a bunch
of furniture that I didn't really want
to pay a mover to like move anywhere yet
the rent was so cheap there that it made
more sense like to just pay the rent use
that place of store stage unit so I was
like [__] it I was paying $1,000 a month
for a three-bedroom house I had hella
[__] in there so it was like all the
[__] I have in here like [__] it I'll
just you know I'll pay the rent for like
an extra month or two you know figured
out ended up becoming an extra like
three or four months cuz it was like I
don't want to go down there and deal
with this yet M I'll just pay again oh
God I don't left the [__] there oh it's
over so um I uh I didn't realize
Tweakers kicked the back door in and uh
just started Living there and they like
stole power from the power lines they
like wired it up to the house and they
just took like everything they towed
both of my cars out they took all your
[__] they pretty much but I had taken
most of my uh like really important
stuff out there wasn't really anything
that I was like like oh man there was
one thing there was one thing um my my
old Rosen press the nug Smasher MH the
one that's the one thing they took where
I was like man wait they stole it all
yeah everything and lives there yeah
they live there and then they the
furniture out and then just Liv in an
empty house they like slowly I guess
emptied it out or whatever like to the
cars place and [__] and neighbors or is
this out in the country or some there's
neighbors they didn't notice well the
neighbors to the right smoked meth and
the neighbors to the left hated me so oh
yeah they were that sounds like Merced
these FS hat the way I found out is
because they so the neighbor uh talked
to my landlord who was the old like the
girl who lived there and she hit up my
landlord one day and she's like hey like
what's up with the new people living
there they're uh stealing power and
she's like what and like she never came
to inspect the crib one time we didn't
have an active lease or anything we had
like no type of any that [__] no it it
wasn't even like a verbal agreement it
was just like I'll pay you some money
and they like here like we in that [__]
like it wasn't we didn't even have an
agreement like oh tell me this much in
advance like nothing the the lease had
expired like two years prior and it was
just like Nick just squatted there from
a lady that said she lived there just
squatting pretty much bro damn near
um so yeah give me money yeah you live
here yeah yeah pretty much pretty much
um so she hit me up and she's like you
got to go down there and get them out
and I'm like dude we have no lease I'm
not doing that like nope that's not my
problem they stole my stuff yeah my
stuff's already gone there's nothing to
fight for you know like I'm not dealing
with that and she was like trying to get
me I just blocked her you blocked your
landlord she wants my landlord anymore I
had an apartment on
you need to go get these people out bro
how is that my responsibility it's your
house call the police yeah totally like
what I think she was like yo you're
renting it from me why the [__] did you
let people I actually don't even live
there lady I just used as storage what
the [__] that's what she's thinking well
the thing is too I mean it wasn't like I
just abandoned it like I had popped in
you know I popped in I popped in you
know but like for a few months I didn't
I was busy but like when I months yeah
for sure Tweakers live there they had a
whole football season is this a regular
neighborhood or is this like a tweaked
out the whole town was [__] except for
one corner of it so oh okay but I just
wasn't expecting that they kicked the
back door in and just moved in um and
also she like she was fully aware that I
wasn't really there like to begin with I
wasn't really like there that much cuz I
was already traveling a lot when I lived
there and then when I moved up north
like pretty sure she knew about that too
so like oh yeah I don't think it's like
she was like what like you know but not
my problem either way bro I'm not
[__] walking in the house and being
like all right guys you have to leave
like yo so so what happened to your cars
they just took them bro they tow them
away I don't know you never got them
well what am I supposed to do call DMV
like they stole these or can you if you
guys found I'm TR here's the problem
though they were never registered to me
because my L's was suspended they were
beaters my L's was suspended um and I
bought those and I was I was driving
around with plates that weren't mine I
would just switch them between cars and
I didn't have a license I didn't have
registration I didn't have insurance you
were a few different drugs away from
being a a fullon regular ass drug addict
you're over here going no these cars
don't work I lost my license I just
switched the plates over man [__] let's
go get some coke like oh my God I was
living different my car now I swear it's
registered to me I I swear I and it's
insured I swear she's like I'm I'm just
R to this kid he does drugs he looks so
nice
so
also what if
meth is like the Limitless pill that's
smoke it because all of them seem to
know how to rewire electricity yeah do
you know how to rewire electricity do
they actually know or like how many
Tweakers do you know can fix a [__]
Engine with no shirt ones in the Sun a
lot how many you know they could rewire
electricity it gives you like vocational
skills I know a lot there you go smoke I
know a lot that sure as hell will try a
twoyear jump I know a lot that'll try
yeah I they actually actually like I
don't know if they actually succeed but
I know a lot how many squeaker steel
power all of them yeah so do you know
how to Ste power I don't I don't know
was like H all right I can see those
lines
inside idea how to do that you're right
what if it is the Limitless pill SL
vocational skill bro you know what I'm
thinking my internet was on auto pay for
a few months I'm thinking they might
have just been using my internet or some
[__] for sure [__] and do you know how
to steal internet like the bo all these
fools are geniuses and there's people
out there going they're crafty bro these
guys are crafty they have survival
skills that like we don't have if the
apocalypse hits that's them they're
going to win if they get a gun it's over
bro the thing is if the apocalypse hits
and you see Tweakers the only thing that
changes is the background because
they're going to look exactly the same
in the apocalypse as they do right now
now cuz those fools could live off of
nothing and just a Pepsi yep a p a Pepsi
one jacket and a pack of new PS one
jacket shoes kind of shoes they're
[__] flopping they can wear the same
pair for 20 years and a pack of New
Ports as long as the bottoms are on the
shoes they'll figure it out thank you as
long as there's bottoms on the that's
what I'm trying to say so look the
reason I say that is because there's a
lot of fools and meret that like build
here too that build mountains on top of
carts uhhuh and they're just Tri they're
like the baby carts in the back have you
seen the engineering bro incredible how
they get to balance sometimes arits it's
amazing you're right meth is a Voca it
depends on what vocational thing going
to give you I like that bro there was a
guy I saw who who had like wood on like
a shopping cart and he had like a spot
for like his bike like he had like a
little bike rack on his cart bro and he
had all you got is time to trick out
your [__] right dude they're pimping up
that's P My Ride Like how sick is your C
and there's a guy that thinks he's
exhibit out there you know mean he's
like yo dog yeah it's got to be a dude
with the sickest card of all like he
pulls up and they're like damn bro that
[__] forign that's a
forign yo when I first moved to LA near
downtown if you're if you're from La
tell me what street cuz I know you
remember Rosie and I just moved here it
was like a two months in and we were
driving no it was like a year in it was
like a year in because we didn't have a
car we first got here we're driving
under a freeway right downtown and I
swear on my life Marty this man
underneath the freeway had a whole
convenience store maybe I told you had
like the metal shelves no no I'm good oh
but it was it did look like a store
there was like five of each thing on
shelves one shelf that was like four
rows another shelf that was like four
rows then he had like a bed a sick cover
over it and a TV bro he's he's living
min toothpaste that a bunch of razors
cans it that
ring unreal and somebody else Liv in La
there was one guy that I wonder if he's
got like address and reviews on like
Google Maps get the [__] out of you can
pull up to his store ghost
kitchen you Uber ghost 7 I'll be pissed
712 72 7247 for the past 30 years I'm on
drugs no the guy had a nice spot like he
had sheet on his bed just on the
sidewalk on the [__] sidewalk guys
under an overpass they're making mini
hes was the TV like the TV was on had
had to have been in like like a like a
generator honestly [__] all of this [__]
I'm I'm going to tap out and do
that the episode I'm just going to pop
up a smoke shop under a bridge he going
to stream yeah he going to stream from
inside the RV y run it and just drive
around you know what I'm moving to like
Montana oh man you'll just do too good
there you'll do too good there like oh
[__] I started I got some land for 17
cents a foot dude like here we go I
started an actual Walmart Super Center
I'm a millionaire dude what the I am
going to build everything on my property
dude I'm going buy be sick I'm going to
buy 100 acres of land we're going to
we're going to build a Costco on that
[__] for nobody just for me personally
yeah just just for you like in case the
Armageddon happens I just want the
kitchen part bro I need the [__] yeah
if the Armageddon happens I'm locking
myself in Costco give me the chicken
bake give me the [__] bro the chicken
bake is it chicken bake how do you feel
about the chicken bake you're talking to
a vegetarian I'm [__] I know I'm sorry
it's
smashed chicken bakes were my [__]
chicken bakes are chicken is like a is
like a vegan replacement for that is
there like anything similar to it I
don't know [__] I have no idea you you
have not ripped that oh oo that's I know
you're high my bad my bad we flew
through here's some more joints here's
some more joints you want to tell
everybody about the guest we just
booked coming in for the end of the
month coming in real real oh yeah we got
Mexican finally booked in super stoked
next week we have uh uh also we have g g
coming in I I watched Dave I think uh
Dave the show is hilarious check this
out smoke that David Cho oh thank you
not David Cho what is this oh Dave show
Little Dicky it's a zic yeah why it pink
it's a pink paper blazy Susan it's
pretty I think it is blazy sus that or
or a pink element
ah yeah very nice all right here we go
let's smoke it up so dude what are your
plans what's going on with you right now
we just talked about a bunch of random
[__] right now content man I've been uh
I've been making a lot of videos uh got
some fun stuff for Pine Park coming up
this year you know just uh expanding
into some different states over there
there you know selling some weed in the
wreck Market um so if in case anybody
didn't see your last episode explain a
little more what you're doing with Pine
Park since you moved out here um so
since I moved out here I I host the Pine
Park podcast but I'm also a part owner
of the brand um yeah yeah like the the
whole brand the weed you know the whole
thing um so we uh currently we're in
California Oklahoma and Michigan
dispensaries but we're planning to go to
some new States this year I don't think
I can say which on um like necessarily
very many but we're coming to some new
states that are really exciting some
popping States so it's going to be dope
um that's been super fun uh the only gas
stuff is dope we're testing out hella
new Growers you know pretty much like
every other week we're just testing out
batches from different different Growers
seeing them what hits um but we've
locked in some really fire [__] glitter
bomb is like probably the strain I'm
most excited to drop soon it's probably
the craziest candy turps I've ever
[__] like ever seen in like the
market I was going to say I like how
you're holding company meetings on
Twitter what bro I [__] spaces bro
say it again holding company meetings on
Twitter bro he told us he said everybody
always messages me about coming and
working for me oh B get a oh I got I saw
that welcome to the team welcome to the
team stupid ass I'm holding no I've been
holding Twitter spaces I held two
company meetings on Twitter what's that
mean Twitter B oh the the live live you
talk yeah you talk to people you can
have people on to chat so like you know
I've been inviting people on asking a
math questions you know like yo you like
accounting department like what's the
answer to this question you know if they
get it wrong I kick him out you know
like damn there a lot of project the
worst like I'm not here for being
accountant I'm a project man I'm done n
bro like people raise their hand for it
you know so like if you raise your hand
for it and you get on the spot and then
you're wrong it's like what are you
doing them out you know oh my God that's
just how it goes bro that's layoffs
budget cuts that's layoffs that's
cutting the trim of the fat yeah dude
those that Bonet got me
again I like this piece MH a lot I like
the bigger as catch yeah it gets way
more suction like you got to actually
like work a little harder to get it
going but once you get it going it's
like forced yeah once you get it going
it goes she said do me a favor can you
bring up your uh Instagram I got another
the video I want to show show Nick
all right here we go
so I did not know I know Marty didn't
know that Nick has a very thriving rap
career starting off oh [__] I heard I
heard that you have a very thriving rap
career I just want to show everybody
real
quick no look at that
picture and tell me it doesn't look
identical I think you sent me that yeah
it's insane freeze freeze frame that put
it
on I have to look at this look at this
my side hustle look side hustle bro it's
your Alter Ego right here this is if I
use the YouTube money to fund the video
this dude this isn't profitable yet yo
this guy's a fan I've seen him many
times JD yeah JDS yeah I've seen him
many times dude he's always commenting
and I clicked on his name one day I went
are you kidding me there's no way so
when I saw this I saw you have you seen
this on Tik Tok no there's like a 20,000
likes on the comments Goblin really
yeah like Tik Tok is Ultimate for inside
jokes and they'll be like Dam this was a
Hoot and Holler and be hell likes on
like damn fools really watch he was
already a fan though yeah that's sick I
seen him pop up before I'm like wait
this is the same dude that always
comments so I just wanted to show dude
it's kind of ridiculous it's you ever
see those uh AIS where it's like Peter
Griffin it's like swag. Peter Griffin I
love those it's like the AI version of
Nick and that m music video it's like
longer hair the Griffin people always
comment Goblin on those bro I see that
[__] all the time bro like is that
Goblin so I had to bring that up I
thought it was hilarious yeah I did say
that to
you I did say that to you already
thought it I thought it was funny that
you got people financing
CS so explain it he's at my house
telling me not explain him full in full
what does that even mean what you have
to explain it what the financing yeah
what does that mean yeah so we uh we use
something called sezzle on uh on only
gas which is uh a paying for payment
platform so you break it down into four
payments it's interest free if you pay
on time I encourage people not to do it
like I tell people like listen like
don't you know like just pay for it you
know but people actually ask for it and
people use it a lot um so you can get
get it and then just make payments on a
car is insane yeah people have been
doing can you front me we can front now
that's insane can front just make a
deposit you know that's W you got 10
bucks I'll take what you got right now
how long you been having that going like
that um the Brand's only been running
for a little over a month uh we just got
started um before that we were doing a
lot of bag design and trying to figure
out like what strains I really wanted to
to release um it's kind of like the
honor System though right like you got
to what that you're like fronting them
and they're getting it and then paying
so the way it works is um they give us
all the money up front like CLE pays the
the vendor up front yeah um oh so they
got to deal with CLE they they make
their money through people not paying on
time which yeah yes which why I tell
people like listen bro like if you're
not going to pay that [__] don't do it
yeah you know gotcha so you don't even
got to deal with it if they don't pay
that's cool
yeah it's not my problem so do you have
fan reviews do you have anybody leaving
comments yet on anything um we're
starting to gather reviews but how much
ridiculous shit's in there I haven't we
just literally like last night just
started like sending out emails for
people to write them so we're going to
see bro it's going to get ridiculous bro
I got a review the other day for our
flower just listen to the
words here hold on hold on sorry sorry
I'm sitting here my isn't really hitting
same I'm trying to rip it I'm trying to
like tweak it my shit's not hit yeah I
was trying to tweak it it's not really
hitting [__] maybe because I I normally
love ztics I unpack these maybe I don't
know so I'm sitting here at work with my
lady twisted up a joint took some fat
rips here we are our astral projection
image is having its own astral
projection this strand is
amazing having an out of Body Experience
Asal projection is having his
own that's so fire oh my God I met
people there was one guy oh there was
one I love so there's a guy who ordered
a cart um and he messaged me and the
cart was like barely not filled to the
top and he's like bro it looks like
someone was ripping my [__] shut what
the [__] is this like he sent a video
and he's like this is [__] up and then
like 20 minutes later and he's like yo
man I'm high as [__] never
mind so is he accepted it or went maybe
it's not smoked yeah he I guess he
smoked it and he was like all right it's
cool no he said um he was like high as
[__] never mind and then he said uh he
was like even if someone ripped it I'm
cool with that he got high stopped
getting mad about it yeah he that's
cool but it was like funny no carts like
filled all the way to the brim you know
like they [__] they just aren't so
little air bubble room in there yeah
this what I did I went like this and
loosened up the Cherry a little bit see
that's I'm scared of you'll be fine
you'll be
fine Mar most organic time that's ever
been said like this at just so it's a
little looser it might started
ripping okay you've been in La for a
minute you've been doing Instagram and
all this stuff for a while you've been
doing comments and all that in your
memory what is the most wild request
you've had so far for like something for
me to do no anything something they want
something they want to ask whether it's
a service a living for you living with
you and or hiring and living at the
warehouse Andor staying in the room
she'll never see them I had give me
something there was a guy there was a
guy who I honestly was like going to I
was like really debating like bro should
I send this to like the authorities like
this is terrifying right there was a
dude who was explaining how he feels
like he's like I really want to like
become big in the YouTube and weed scene
but like I feel rage and I he's like I
feel anger and like sometimes I feel
like shooting people at my school and
[__] and like he sent me this crazy
essay and I was like bro this is like
serious dude like I didn't answer it but
I was just like dude what the [__] he
was like I feel like a I hate society
and I hate the way that like women are
and like it was like some Intel [__] you
know um but he sent me this long ass
paragraph bro and this was like a year
ago and I was like d a
Manifesto that's what they called bro he
kept sending them to me he sent me like
three or four of them for like a week
and I just never I was like I'm not even
and like bro it was crazy as [__] maybe
it was just some AI [__] I
hope no it wasn't that it was a guy it
was some guy letting you know I need
someone to what was it stop me SME you
better stop me
SME bro I'm not you SME I'm not Superman
I'm not saving just go like I'm not
Captain sa what here we go this what you
do for those people you right back we
all go through batches or something like
that no sometimes like people DM me on
platforms and I'm like oh yeah but this
some dude emails me and he's like bro I
think about shooting people like I'm not
I get I get a lot of De with that
guy oh I know what you're saying CU you
open yourself up to it and then you're
like oh now they're always I like to
write a huge paragraph about good things
and but he shouldn't do them and then I
try not to continue yeah how do you stop
it you don't you just stop you just
don't res it anymore bro so how some
people that are
off how do you how do you deal with
people um yeah of course like dming you
directly for customer support instead of
customer support email I screenshot
their [__] [__] and send it straight
to my guy and I go through a whole text
thread and then I get it done and then I
DM them the
confirmation the past week I've been
going have you contacted customer
service at all
no that's what I say they asked the
podcast like have you tried customer
support crazy to me is when people are
like dog you can't even answer my [__]
I'm trying to get this done I ordered
two hours ago I put the wrong address
help me out I'm like bro what yeah you
can take my money but you can't help me
with my order and I'm I always go with
hey man you got to chill out would you
DM the owner of Nike and be like dog
here's my order number no you hit up
customer service it's a whole department
we have employees for it they can fix it
cuz they got your information right at
their fingertips this is the email it
actually has a whole Tab and if you
didn't have the tab direct link gotch
you
man I don't say that I just go hey have
you contacted service if not they can
help you out right here boom every day
people hit me up for it and I will try
to help them sometimes people like I hit
a customer service yesterday haven't
contact to me then I'm like oh maybe
they slip through the crack and it's
always Chad hits me back goes we've
already talked to that guy like four
hours ago I don't know why he's I'm
sorry bro he's like I'm sorry I don't
know why they're call like oh all right
it's like 90% of the time they're like
yeah we we already talked to them like
[__] dude they just want to talk to you
like they I mean just talk and say hi I
think there's a good amount people who
just want to use it as an excuse to like
talk to you you know I I answer DMS yeah
yeah I answer them and I I answer DMS
too but also I try to like I just try to
direct people to support I'm like bro
yes if it's they're going to do more
than I can like I'm not at the warehouse
right now I can't ship your order myself
but they can that's exactly what I've
doing lately yeah exactly like um not
like a copy based but I do yeah I kind
of say I'm just like hey like the
automatic reply pretty much I need to
have one of those on my like like yo
support can help you out um they're
there like five days a week you know
[__] here's their their contact
they're actually at the warehouse right
now you know get in touch get in touch
yeah yeah get in touch um so you had a a
Manifesto get dropped on you damn near
yeah kind of scarily that's cool man all
right not no all right no can't stop it
it's not cool it's kind of cool dropped
it at him but he deflected that [__]
yeah he did he hit Circle he spun yeah
I'm not I'm not dealing with that [__]
bro like listen you want to go on a
rampage he that's your own life path you
know that's that's a life path I can't
stop that tell him that I I'm not
telling him that no cuz then I'm then
I'm getting involved hell no I get it I
get it I get it I'm not saying there his
computer screen going like I'm not
getting I'm also not going to try to
stop this crazy man who wants to shoot
people I'm not it's my email I could
just close my eyes I just Clos it you
know [__] that [__] I can close my eyes
I can just delete that [__] are you
kidding
me what you been what you been listening
to watching it's the best new music show
you've seen recently um Playboy cardi is
supposed to drop soon but uh it's like
the end of January and he the album's
not here so that's cool man who knows
you know he dropped a couple songs
though um that were pretty
good uh besides that V had a really good
album who uh v v never heard he's uh
he's from Detroit he's pretty good uh
his newest album is fire super fire very
good it's like kind of like weird at
first if you've never listened to him
before but once you once you bump a few
times it's like okay you know I kind of
get it now Detroit's having a whole
movement right now artist coming out of
there Detroit's popping dude yo you know
what's not popping damn
Lions I'm glad the ners won cuz I like
I'm California but Lions almost [__]
made it man dude the Lions have not made
it in so long it's sad they said they've
never been to the Super Bowl they never
will bro I realized they're actually way
bigger losers than we are and like
they've never even went
yeah talking bills guys not saying
losers like those guys the bills are
good the bills are like you know you got
you're situated you got some good
players
[__] just put out a bunch of candles
yeah right hold on that's how sad the
side was listen I'm a Bears fan oh
that's right you're a Bears fan we had a
good season in the [__] 80s I say
1988 and that has been our Legacy
forever yeah that's it that's all you
guys have ever had do you care about
anything beyond uh the Bears like the
Super Bowl or anything this is going out
to um I'm going to watch the Super Bowl
I watched uh this past Sunday I watched
uh a couple days ago CH and the uh right
I was like what it's going to be before
the Super Bowl so who who's are you
betting like who's your picks I don't
know bro ners is going to win you think
yeah but it's Patrick Mahomes and they
got Taylor Swift and Travis Kel 100% but
Taylor Swift's there to bring the
eyeballs
be there with her whether or not they
win or
lose I think okay but I do think NFL
scripted I don't I've seen too many
Clips where I'm like they even try to
tackle him why
not I think it's like those guys can
paid enough money to shut up about it I
think so it made me sad dude they
probably pay him 300 million for hush
money shut up money Jesus Christ Our
Flawless kicker he's basically not
missed a kick in [__] three seasons
goes out there misses I'm pretty sure he
was like a 30 yarder said 40 but I mean
it wasn't that far he has literally
hasn't missed in years I feel like maybe
once and he missed the one to tie it up
yeah I don't know man but I did remember
going the 90s are down
17 probably come back OG's like Las
Vegas like damn do they have such a a
hold on it but no no because everybody's
going to start betting that the lions
are going to take it the now going to
come back I think it's all this is like
a lot of money thing I I try to avoid
Sports B unless it's UFC UFC oh you're
talking because the sport is not as
reliable yeah got you got you um UFC
next month yeah February month it's
coming to Anaheim in Anaheim volan
volcanos let's go I'm so unbelievably
down to go we looked at the tickets
they're not insane how how much how much
for front right up front right up
1400 I'll see you there it's not insane
right
wow when I go to Vegas tonight you're
going to make that I run this table I'll
tell you what I'll see you there let's
go I'll [__] see you there yeah I was
supposed to go to Vegas yesterday with
John and then the dates were just didn't
work like no John still out there he
left this morning oh hell he's on his
way out there now so uh he's going Eric
going I'm like damn I'm not going
anymore but I do have a lot of [__] to
get done so it's it's I think I'm going
to go out there for the Super Bowl with
April like not to go not to go to it
like April just Dan you hear Marty I
think I'm G to go
somewhere whoa it's a new year it's
aligning with Valentine's W New Year
about things oh wait hold on I have to
be in Vegas on Valentine's Day for
Champs
so be there too well I mean I just hate
flying if I can not fly I'd be so
stoked all right [__] flying here we go
so go cast February only gas is going
you're literally about to drive away to
Vegas he let out of
being that's how I feel cuz I woke up my
dude are you driving cuz you hate flying
so much um I just you know the way I
look at it's like by the time I get
through TSA and then get on the damn
plane it's almost the same amount of
time bro you know I'm just and then I
have my car out there so you know I have
some friends that live out there oh
that's cool did we talk about on here
the video of the [__] door getting
ripped off the plane in the air oh my
god dude Boeing listen I've been saying
for years that Boeing planes are not
safe I've been saying for years that
Boeing planes are not made you feel that
way because uh you can look at the
accident rates look at Airbus planes
Airbus planes they're made in Europe
they have like they have a few models
that have had no accidents caused by the
plane it's only pilot air right no
accidents out of millions and millions
of flights no zero accidents caused by
the plane whoa yeah their planes are
real as [__] like if you whenever I book
a flight I look and I try to pick Airbus
if I can what's the Airbus like what is
that it's a brand I've it's a Boeing
competitor really like United Delta
Airbus no no no that's the airline but
the like the actual plane brand I you
know about this [__] so when you if you
book through Google flights you can you
can see it anywhere uh but if you go on
Google flights you click the drop down
on the flight you want to book and in
the bottom it'll say that the type of
plane so you're mindful of what type of
plane you're writing on yeah I asked
Rosie too I don't fly on the max ones
the max ones I just ask her not to get
me the skinny ones those are if you're
going to fly on a Boeing fly on a one of
the like OG ones like the 737 or some
[__] you know really yeah do you think
like it has the potential to go down all
the time or uh well I think the max ones
are scary cuz they're newer planes
Boeing's just cutting a lot of Corners
you know that's why the [__] bolts
are loose and all this shit's happening
and a few years ago remember when the
max planes got grounded cuz they crashed
over the ocean and [__] there was two
Max planes that went down and killed
everyone on board and they grounded all
of them for like a while uh and then
they brought them back pretty quickly
and the reason that the planes went down
is um I'm not I might not be 100%
correct but off my memory is because the
planes like they made him like bigger to
call him the max right but in instead of
actually building like the engines and
the wings bigger to like make it Fly
normally they just made it Fly normally
with software cuz the weight wasn't
balanced very well so sometimes it would
just like [__] up and like the plane
just nose dive so literally like there
was a fight where the plan
just went down sh me Jesus yeah yeah
it's crazy as [__] um be so pissed and
then now they got the loose [__]
bolts on the do door popped off during a
flight [__] that that was one of those
yeah it was a Max plane was a Max plane
don't fly on them [__] did don't you
get on a b you watch the Netflix movie
about the the soccer team or the rugby
team that crashed on the one of the
Mount Everest or whatever I've seen that
yes yes that's crazy as [__] oh God man
it's [__] up that was horrible what
the worst part about it quick spoiler
alert like a couple of the people ended
up living in this scenario yeahh
my Lu I'll live and be stuck out there
forever it like it took them so long
this was my big takeaway it's it's the
worst situation you could ever imagine
there's cannibalism gone down our
situation ever but like they if they
would have left right away they waited
they were like waiting if they would
have just gone right away they could
have got out in like less than two weeks
probably it only took them like 10 days
to get to where they needed to go to
where they but they were there for like
months oh yeah that's the um
oh my god dude what's the movie called
we just Emily and I just watched that
[__] the other day it's like say it has
snow in the title it was in Spanish the
hell
yeah snow piercing I had to read the so
uh subtitles I didn't yeah snow P that
sounds right y k snow old one Society of
the snow is the one I'm talking about no
thanks 72
days a rugby team mhm yeah their
destination like to get help was just 10
days away they they were like eating
each other and [__] alive no no killing
each other to eat no they were starving
and freezing and then oh they like oh
well he's dead let's eat him and then it
became very normal where they were just
like just like chicken
wings
munching yeah they're they're they're
they're athletic just make the trk
eventually some of them did they thought
there a point came where they realized
weren't going to be rescued that they
given up for the whole
season so they were like trying to wait
out a rescue and then they realized they
weren't going to get rescu for the whole
[__] thing and then they started
trekking out and they you know some
people died and it wasn't but some dude
made it to the point of another person
70 some days in but took him 10 days to
get to that location two months to
finally walk some [__] like that it
would have been maybe maybe 12 hours
there day three 12 hours in i' be like I
think it's time to go
I mean you're on the no day three you're
right so in case rescue comes yeah
you're right because it's to the point
that okay we're going to hike all day
we're going to sleep in the freezing
blizzard of a mountain hopefully we live
hike another just to get to the top of
that Ridge over there and we get there
and you look out and it's just endless
mountains [__] dude that's terrifying
bro that's scary as [__] dude that's
horrifying I rather go out freezing
walking and dying you just freeze and
just like why always say if I'm going to
freeze I'm going to pose sick oh you
want to know the really [__] up part
damn not the death God this isn't even
like they're going through all that huge
spoiler alert all right still watch
brand new
movie I don't know might yesterday don't
go watch this I'm you got to still watch
this this is a story from the 70s people
know this story or whatever it is Banger
death they be eating each other the
variable that you're not thinking about
cuz you're like okay we're going to stay
in the plane we're in a it's like Arctic
freezing on top of this huge mountain
and you start getting slammed with
Avalanches oh yeah the aval now you're
in the plane boom a wave of Snows now
buried you so now you're on top of the
person beneath you they're trying to get
out you're trying to get out trying to
blast through the window of the plane
it's like drowning in water but it's
freezing
snow so now you go through essentially
another plane crash
that
mad bro flying is scary flying is
scarier now like I got over it for a bit
and now it's scary again I feel you now
they're cutting corners on the planes
and [__] and they're I'm air is the way
air bus bro I'm telling you fly safe
you'll be conscious of that before we
get out of here can i r that one more
time yes of course
bro um as just something to poke it out
with Y here you go um thank you so yeah
this was
a this was fun this is a early morning
one I feel so different awak B so when
are you going to when are you going to
how and when are you planning on letting
people know about this big news you're
going to drop in oh I got to wait a
little bit big news yeah the big news I
told you before we started ah yeah yeah
um I'm going to wait a little bit M yeah
cuz it's it's brand new it just happened
I want to wait a second just to really
get my highle chess [__] going on right
now for 2024 though that's for damn big
chess makes me nervous but I'm
good damn yeah it's huge it's you ever
get into playing chess oh yeah yeah I
just do this hurry up hurry up just keep
moving that's how I play I go oh you w
don't [__] I had a stretch where I
played against my dad like before school
every morning when I was like seven what
every morning I mean like what you want
me to grind up a short stretch we you
know take
taught me a couple little tricks and
[__] really yeah see Marty left this
part out his dad was a chess
genius yo my dad was a straight hippie
like white dude he he had that Charles
Manson kind of look like long hair
hippie chest genius bro yeah and he had
the chest hair chess genius he was
living out he lived in La for a stretch
so did my mom independently of each
other oh [__] but he lived he taught
Chess at a park in Compton
in the 70s turns out Marty's dad was an
actual CIA agent right infiltrating the
music in Buffalo New York because Rick
James was there and they really wanted
to know what was going on
OJ Jesus he actually taught random
random fun fact yeah but then he taught
me just just a quick fun one my dad
actually CIA operative got be thinking
now
yeah teach a music class in all
actuality someone went in they never
came out every time he had new students
every time it was actually aill fight
off your dad's just a bad he's going to
open up his award like there's a note
it's your
turn oh Marty's all pissed I just got
comfortable man that
[__] it opens hologram if you're
watching
this that means as soon as I strum the
guitar one time oh Marty
just like like an aladdin like an
aladdin when he starts
to that's smart he just
flip-flop hair grows Mike cem romance
starts to play real [__] I like it all
right here we go you're like the Prince
of Persia but just of like hippie
operatives here we go again even though
the bong's here I still wanted to do
this uhhuh it's yeah it's just wa
well you know you've been podcasting now
you must have tried to light the mic a
few times few times like this yeah I've
gone in a little bit you know like
a oh man all right before we leave
because I know you have to start driving
after you got high as [__] for two hours
and the we early ass mornings and hours
yep you might actually yeah you might
you're going to be traffic you might
miss some traffic you are going to be
traffic uh so you're driving straight
there you're going to be there for what
three days uh yep I leave on uh Friday
good [__] for hash and GL Vegas nice
yeah I don't uh I don't have tickets
either so we'll see how I'm getting in
uh I'm just getting high it's been a
long time since you've been deleted too
right
um yeah it's been a good bit but I'm
Shadow banned as [__] right now my
account doesn't show up in searches or
feeds and it type it all the way in I
haven't been posting reals because of
that it just you know doesn't really get
anywhere you know did you already start
a new one for the podcast uh yeah I have
one I need to post
yeah just start got start posting Clips
the uh the like pilot app we did but
I'll get on that it's cool you got the
experience with Pine park now like yeah
yeah to really get into it before you
start your own [__] yeah I'm is there a
start date on that or like a when you to
there's not like an exact date but in
February it should be should be getting
cooked up so should be should be
dropping very soon uhhuh well let us
know we will talk to Spotify and get
that [__] video [__] yeah yeah
we need to be on there we that's the
future that's likeu appreciate that they
actually want us they like us they're
like it's weird let's go dude them and
Twitter only platforms I guess huh I'm
still not going to call it X though yo
you know what though Facebook loves drug
content I've been all [__] onbook it's
getting Millions like these clips one of
your Clips it's got over a million on
there the uh on Facebook yeah
yeah Facebook goes hard for the clips
for some reason really we had a couple
over like one or two million robbery and
reveng
you uh in the bathroom oh Rob your boy
oh [__] Jesus Christ they just go I
don't even think about them they just
all the all the drug contact goes crazy
on Facebook bro I'm going have to start
posting on that do you like plug it on
your YouTube and stuff like like our
Facebook no I just I post on every
channel every time I post it goes up on
everything
independently damn yeah Facebook is for
some reason like stories they're dope
almost 160k on there in like 4 months
with zero effort
[__] did they monetize no well they
we got like three cents in our [__]
account oh okay all right so you're
working towards a
dollar
what
yo some lollipops I buy at the gas
station is the 30 cents so oh there you
go if we get a dollar we get all ad doll
we had a billion views on there we might
there you go that's the [__] cop one
of them things that's not even too bad
[__] lollipop yo it's crazy it's cool
though it's cool because that's why we
have to do other things and it makes us
not just we just make videos and that's
it because other YouTubers have the
luxury of going I made $40,000 off two
video like oh my God bro it's crazy man
we have to like start Brands and really
like like
Enterprise like actually do some stuff
you know which is fine but for all the
new [__] on Instagram it's the GBL Ln
yes Twitter the goblin with three NS
that's right the goblin with three ends
because the guy won't give it up yeah
YouTube Goblin just Goblin Tik Tok uh I
don't really post you don't really post
I got locked out yeah bro I I mean I
just they delete everything I post so
what about kick is that like a VI
kick.com Goblin but um I don't really
stream a on there I'm mainly on Twitch
gbn 420 gbn 420 yeah see it's such a
bummer that everybody takes all the
variations of names yeah we should just
have the same [__] dude it's so hard to
remember well there's a DOT no it's it's
actually if you type in Goblin when I'm
live on most of them it'll come up or
like you know when when you're trying to
find me um Instagram's the only one
we're like yeah you probably got to type
my name I read that your name before was
g a h b l i n or some [__] yeah yeah
there some dude there's some dude who
was yeah there was some guy who was in
like a like a call Call of Duty Clan uh
that had more subs than me that uh
called himself like Goblin and I was
like [__] bro I can't I can't use that
name cuz then I'd be a fan boy you know
so I gota like change it you know so
then he just fell off or what yeah I
just got I got I was like well I'm back
yeah you know that was back in the day
when I did a lot of like Call of Duty
[__] that once I started doing more of
the like drug stories I was like no I'm
just I'm going with Goblin yeah yeah um
I respect that yeah just was what it was
here we are yeah it was what it was like
all right we're getting into it but by
then he was probably gone so I didn't
really look into it I was just like [__]
it if you're going to take the name live
up to this [__] for sure but yo we got
the [__] air going there's fruit it's
early morning this feels like a early
morning brisk day it feels bom I feel
like there's so much more room of the
day left it's not 7 at night right now
it's 1 yeah we've been here for over
just two hours I like filming in the
morning this is sick one should start
waking up earlier cuz I do feel like
this a little like I'll go I'll go to
sleep if I was at home right now I'll
sleep that's how I feel you got to drive
I'm sorry I have hell of [__] to do too
but this is just like a a good start
respect the Siesta the Siesta people
that embraced the Siesta got it right
get up early go ham take that little nap
why not then have the rest of your day
that sounds bomb right that's how you're
supposed to do I would like to do that I
don't do that but I like the idea I
would like to do that that sounds bomb
as fun I respect people that do the [__]
I don't do
[__] [__] um all right so for all
platforms Go cast is coming soon only
gas all right catchup episode this is
fun and since we've seen you've been
actually hosting and doing your own
thing doing your [__] you so that first
episode you're all [__] Reckless and
[__] you came in
like two years time I mean I'm so
reckless just like business-wise you
know you're way more calmed down bro on
you drove here true true you shitfaced
on the Uber I mean if I was shitfaced I
probably still would you got here early
true on the earliest episode we've ever
done true you're pretty you're respon
you're responsible man all right you're
not stealing license plates and [__]
changing
hubcaps you're doing good man you're
responsible and got your car like no
this is a better choice I would say from
the first time we got here super
responsib yeah good flip good business
flip and I like it now you're part of
like three more companies yeah literally
do my thing do my thing I love it dude
so go
cubis uh is was fuma fumo is coming soon
this year we're uh in a few months we're
going to be revealing some stuff you
know getting ready to do some very very
sick stuff um and Pine Park and Pine
Park and only guas and four yeah so you
got a portfolio going man yeah only gas
[__] shout out my friends at Bas
smokes for making it possible you know I
wouldn't be able to do it without their
Logistics they the amount of a it's so
much work bro it's insane it's insane
it's like that every day like oh that oh
this this this and thank God there's
people that can think like that thank
[__] God I can't do that man I can't
like I just go how much do you sell
inventory I love being able to just
mainly do like you know responding to to
people blew by like you know responding
to customers smoking the weed being like
this is good this is not I get so much
[__] weed sent to me like every few
days it's like yeah ridiculous right
[__] pick this pick this pick this
like what do you like you know and it's
just like it's so fun like all these
different turps I just I'm just like yo
I want to try these turps you know and
then like we just try to find whatever
we can get you know like what the best
[__] iteration of that is um it's so
fun bro it's so fun I love that [__]
just smoking weed all the time triangle
yes no no no yes I feel like I feel like
a u wine smaler like I feel like I'm
just like having little sips like a
little bowl like H exactly you know it's
exactly what it is you guys are
professionals yeah you know exactly what
this will not hit people will not like
this yeah like no this isn't small
number of people like this not worth
even putting a skew out yep yes dude you
have to start thinking of like not just
what you like I know I'm not a huge blue
dream fan but our Blue Dream pen sells
like the more affordable [__] that I've
been doing I definitely don't consider
my PR references but like the top end
[__] yeah that's like my like selected
like that's like the the goblin hand
selected [__] you know like this is my
you know my stash you know cuz remember
I told you I was like we're thinking
about doing Smalls we want people get
mad about the quality and you're like
bro people love Smalls no people really
do we actually um we just dropped some
some Greenhouse [__] Smalls and I
tell people like listen bro these are
mid that's a straight de
but we're doing ounces for 65 bucks
they're already the event sold out we're
trying to get more but like you know and
it's like listen bro like you're not
here for TPS you're not here to ask
about the strain you're not here for
pretty [__] you're here solely if you
just want to get high for a good price
it's like $22.30 a gram you
know
it's I mean it is what it is you're
getting what you pay for there's a
dollar menu for a reason bro you know
what you're getting and people love it
you you know what
that product so the uh the ounce of
greenhouse [__] cuz I was trying to
figure out I was like yo how can we just
get like the most budget [__] nugs
cuz we had Smalls of the good [__] for
like a 100 bucks an ounce right but
we're like how can we get like
Greenhouse Smalls like how can we like
really get the best just THC straight to
people's lungs you know l l bottom [__]
yeah you know like it's not it's not
beautiful but it's [__] two bucks
guys has to be that price um it has to
be it has to be yeah that's just that's
where it is and it's a volume thing like
we don't make like crazy [__] money
selling them fill that demand yes
exactly see our fear was are people
going to get mad at us that it's like
hey this is not what I get for 90 and my
uncle like your uncle grows fire what
are you talking about you don't pay
overhead [__] it's outside I mean I
think you know a lot of like you know
when I look at the stats of like the the
people that are buying the only gas and
I'm checking out like back end and stuff
a lot of those people kind of live in
[__] you know a lot of people who who
end up buying like thca they're in an
area where they can't really get it
which makes a lot of sense you about the
bottom [__] um any of the [__] but like
well main the bottom [__] the top end
[__] is like like people in like Cali
buy that which is like you know big
state you know yeah California dude
[__] um what's it called but I get
like for for like the smalls in
particular yeah it's a lot of people in
places that they just can't get weed
like yeah what's the F bang for my buck
[__] smoke and that's it you know um
it's like wind in a box versus like the
[__] you got to go behind the oh I need
to get that out of the case yep and it's
legally delivered bro it's like [__]
dude even like that [__] even the smalls
I feel like is better than the [__] that
I was buying off half my plugs in high
school like well I mean cuz thca is just
weed yes it's just weed like and and
like half the [__] that just the weed
weed standards as a whole nowadays like
what is classified as as like the
[__] now is so crazy well I grew up
here yeah different you live different
you live different I know what trash
weed is we were smoking [__] bro we
were smoking seen SM trash P cow patty
outdoor dog [__] brick weed I have when
I was a kid didn't know who to get it
from well I know the neighbor probably
had 10 packs of fire yeah you know but
it's different out here
yeah I it's a blessing to be out here
yeah so basically I could see why people
could like a cheap ass SCE yep it say I
don't care for the taste bro I'm just
smoking while I'm fix my
car I can see that like mechanic and
[__] or the college student like bro I
just smoke a boow every night this last
me two months MH I get it I totally
understand but damn yeah that's all it's
like ipas versus like give me that 211 M
give me that exact give me that Steel
Reserve please you know what you're
getting still get you high still get you
drunk it's straight up you know it's
just different kind of high you know
it's just that's a high you know and
well what was it tra or die let it go
run it um all right good [__] dude I
know you have to get on the road and you
have to start driving not right out
right away we're going to wait a while
yep yep viit it's time to go yeah all
right have a couple drinks is that what
you said a couple drinks of course Jesus
Christ time for a good booze cruise a
booze cruise by yourself oh yeah that's
just called alcoholism who's drinking on
the way to Vegas to go to a weed event
tomorrow no he's going to hit on the
blackjack table immediately I'm going
hard tonight that's all I know and then
we go to the UFC oh let's go I'm so hype
I'm so hype all right thank you so much
for being here man thank you for being
here the earliest episode for me of good
[__] early morning Marty's got his whole
day ahead of Marty's been up for 5 hours
we all got our whole days ahead of us
I'm so excited what a great time what a
great time got some [__] um [__] yeah so
thank you so much everybody go follow
the socials oh [__] I'm like what is
that sorry in the in the camera it's the
bug no it's fun no no leave it okay I
just would looked at like what the [__]
and I'm staring at it
sorry all right it's a good day um guys
thank you so much for being here this is
Marty this is Goblin this has been a
high ass episode the early morning wake
and bake episode that's a great title
wake and bake with Goblin I feel it I
feel like oh we didn't have to go to
school
today smoke as soon as we wake up I
haven't done that in a minute man like
just wake up and just chill with people
get high it's been a minute yeah like a
long time actually unless I'm on like in
a cabin this a great way can bake this a
great way to start my uh my Vegas day so
let's run it guys thank you so much for
being here we appreciate you this has
been the dope as usual podcast I hope
you smoked along with us and if you
didn't I hope you smoke along later and
if you're at work I'm sorry if you're at
school even worse but remember you can
you're going to go home soon and if
you're driving please be safe I
am I could feel this right
here sorry guys thank you so much if
you're driving please be safe this is
the dope's usual podcast have a dope ass
day nice let's
does banger good [__] guys oh Banger I
can tell real effort to like get that
last part out it
[Music]
was
perfect
[Music]